in the third trial pertaining to the
january 6 insurrection as cnn likes to
call it
the judge agreed with the defendant the
police let them in the building and
therefore there's no trespassing and
nothing else makes sense after that oh
i'd just like to gloat on this one for a
minute because the young turks told me
or they told everyone i made the dumbest
argument by saying if people are fanned
in by police with no warning to leave
you can't convict them for trespass and
here we are now there was another trial
where a man was convicted of trespassing
but this is because
the same judge was like you've you
climbed over some barrier and could
clearly see it was closed off so you
knew what you were doing but as for
those who were waved in by the cops and
the doors open we may be seeing a wave
of acquittals for people who actually
decide to go on trial in this instance a
bench trial so we'll definitely talk
about that we have a major scandal
involving black lives matter it's being
reported
and this is this is crazy this is a scam
this is scandalous
someone from associated with blm bought
a mansion for 3.1 million dollars and
then six days later sold it to blm for
5.8 million dollars where'd that 2.7
million dollars go and why why did it
happen this way
it seems some people believe
that they were trying to funnel money
from the nonprofit into private hands so
we'll go through that story plus we're
going to talk about man democrats are in
for an apocalyptic november in
pennsylvania republicans are converting
democrats four times faster than the
inverse stem people quitting the
republican party are not doing it at
relative to the other way around long
story short democrats are quitting so
it's going to get crazy we got some
polls to show you joining us today to
talk about all of this is the one and
only andrew clavin how you doing do you
want to introduce yourself must i yes i
guess i i guess i will i'm andrew clavin
i'm the host of the andrew clavin show
on the daily wire i'm the author of the
truth in beauty which was my my latest
book and the author of a million other
books uh most of them crime novels and
uh here i am awesome well thank you for
hanging out good sir should be fun it's
uh it's a pleasure to be here absolutely
appreciate it we got sheamus i'm seamus
coghill and i've never written nor even
read anything as long as a crime novel
i'm a cartoonist i have a youtube
channel called freedom tunes every week
we upload a new cartoon and we do it on
thursdays so if you guys want to go and
check out the video we uploaded today i
think you'll very much enjoy it it's
about disney and their proclivity for
whatever reason for like having groomers
working for the organization go check it
out
it's also very much like how uh with
katanji brown jackson they were like the
first black supreme court justice yes
and then it's like i mean aside from the
fact fact that clarence thomas is
currently there thurgood marshall i
think like a long time ago it's
constantly first it's the first time and
people have joked about this before that
there have been about 13 instances of
disney introducing the first gay
character in one of their films and i
sort of took that and connected it to
what's going on added a little bit of a
twist to it i think you guys will enjoy
it maybe you should have a little
sympathy because they may be caught in a
time loop oh yeah you know and they're
they're desperately trying to break out
that's how they're signaling to you
maybe joe biden's doing their pr he's
like a first time man
he's a gay guy in a movie i think time i
can't let it pass that you also do the
best ben shapiro imitation oh that's
honestly i'm very flattered thank you
very much i i do appreciate that this is
coming from somebody okay this comes
from someone who actually works with
entrepreneur and knows the amount of
personal level right folks
it was good you were able to maintain
that you weren't ben shapiro but you
were ben shapiro i was like a little bit
ben shapiro okay you should hear ben
shapiro's impression of me though
yeah yeah
well hey i mean crossland guys looking
forward to talking maybe about god and
the truth oh i like that the idea of
objective truth i asked you before the
show if you thought there was and you
said yes that's kind of the conversation
we often have because i think that there
is no i think that everything is subject
every human every human experience is
subjective through that human but we'll
get into it maybe we can get into it
just happen to be completely incorrect
yeah
i love you and there's no tim cass irl
without me i have to be here in the
corner and i am indeed pushing buttons
tonight so let's get started before we
get started head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com
and you can get virtual shields virtual
private network service this is a basic
layer of security for you as you browse
the web so it prevents creepy hackers
governments and corporations from
stealing your data now no security is
perfect but it is a basic layer defense
and if you're concerned about your data
being stolen this is a really good idea
again surfing internetsafe.com and as we
talk about the january 6 incident and
the committee i'll just give you a good
example
they they've been subpoenaed filing
subpoenas to these uh big tech providers
to get the private text messages of
individuals and the big tech companies
are like yes you're no problem here you
go just hand over the information if
they were using a virtual private
network they'd say all of the
information we've funneled was encrypted
we can't give you anything but they
didn't so surfing internetsafe.com
and you can get virtual shield 50 off
for life when using their vpn service
your traffic is routed through their
secure and encrypted servers this means
any restrictions censorship blocks on
your internet are bypassed it's free for
30 days available on mac windows iphone
ipad android and chrome it does all the
work for you your entire connection
becomes secure private and encrypted and
it will actually encrypt your wi-fi
connection as well blocking hackers and
everyone else from stealing your data
they got personal family and business
plans available family plan includes 15
devices business plan allows you to add
as many employees as you need over at
surfing internet save virtual shield has
been with us from the beginning so we're
eternally grateful thanks so much guys
check them out and don't forget head
over to timcast.com to help support our
journalists who write many of the
stories that we actually use for this
show as a member you'll get access to
exclusive episodes of the tim cast irl
podcast we will have one up for you
tonight at 11 p.m again at timcast.com
so don't forget smash that like button
right now subscribe to this uh youtube
channel share the show with your friends
take that link post it wherever you can
because we have no marketing budget for
the show we've never marketed this show
it's just organic you guys have been
sharing it so much for some reason
people keep watching and we we really do
appreciate it but let's talk about this
first story we got from timcast.com
new mexico man acquitted of charges
related to january 6. the federal
defense contractor is the first person
to be found not guilty of all charges
filed against him in connection to the
capital security breach
matthew martin a federal defense
contractor was acquitted on april 6
following a two-day bench trial martin
had been charged with entering and
remaining in a restricted building
disorderly and disruptive conduct in a
restricted building violent entry and
disorderly conduct in a capitol building
and parading demonstrating or picketing
in a capitol building u.s district judge
trevor n mcvadden said that the first
charge of entering and remaining in a
restricted building was a close call but
that there was a reasonable doubt
whether martin knew he was entering a
restricted building mcfadden also said
the government failed to show evidence
of martin crossing the police line which
mobs of protesters had broken before
he had arrived at the capitol during his
april 5th testimony martin said he went
with the flow
so here we are this is fascinating
for the people who tore down the
barricades tore the the signs down
attacked cops well of course they're
going to get convicted there's video
evidence of them attacking people but
we've long maintained that there is
reasonable doubt for those the magami
maws they call them who fumbled and
bumbled their way into the building as
police fanned them in so uh can i say i
was right that was right yeah no you're
absolutely correct i was right
because i said this back in january
andrew clavin's seal of approval you
know very it's very rare that federal
cases go to trial because people are so
terrified by the federal government
because the federal government doesn't
mess around when they put you away for
15 years you stay away for 15 years
there's no time off for good behavior so
when they come to you and they say well
we'll give you four years instead people
confess and they plead guilty
but but you don't you just don't have to
do it especially if there was and as in
this case there was video of the guy
being let in that's right yeah uh and
this is the video that we referenced
back in january where you see the door
open and then there's there's actual
audio where you can hear a cop say i
don't agree with it but i would but i
respect it or something like that that's
a cop yeah you've got cops taken selfies
with protesters so this is the third
jury this is the third trial there's
been one jury trial and two bench trials
the bench trial with uh judge um
mcfadden i believe his name is mcfadden
the guy was acquitted on the the charges
of disorderly or whatever
he was like just entering isn't
disorderly so acquitted
but you did you know climb up an outer
wall and you knew you weren't supposed
to be in there so you're getting
trespassed right but what's that really
going to be i think the the entire
january 6th narrative is in the gutter
at this point what you have you have
that that uh
disconnect between the democrats
narrative and what happened what
happened was bad i don't think you
should charge into the capital i don't
think you should make our congress
people afraid except of being dis you
know unelected
but they've turned it into the reichstag
fire they've turned it into the biggest
emergency that ever hit the country and
now we need all you know every
republican is supposed to feel like a
criminal and that's ridiculous let's
look uh let's let me pull the scene in a
headline real quick this is how cnn
frames it man who said january 6 was
magical acquitted in u.s capital riot
case you see
this is why people don't understand
what's happening in the world because
when you see that headline and you're a
cnn reader or viewer you assume this guy
is a writer who is violent they called
it a riot case he said it was magical
but they don't give you the context in
the headline right of course
yeah i mean it's ridiculous you
mentioned earlier the fact that the
federal government tends to convict i
think their prosecution rate is
something above 95 because like you said
people are usually willing to take plea
deals
and it's not as if they're sitting there
messing around looking for reasons to
let somebody off they weren't able to
convict this guy because there was
reasonable doubt whether he
intentionally trespassed and there have
been at this point dozens if not
hundreds of people who were there who
have repeated this narrative that they
were waved in by the police they did not
know they weren't supposed to be there
obviously people who broke in who
legitimately trespassed who broke down
the barriers like you mentioned
those are criminals but there are many
people who thought that they were
allowed to be there based on the conduct
of the police and so for the young turks
to come smear you because you speak my
goodness
the good name besmirched the good name
of sir timothy cast over his prediction
which turned out to be correct is
frankly hilarious they own themselves
you know what gets me really is that the
process is the punishment in this
situation this did this guy sit in
solitary for a year like a lot of these
other people probably so he's like in a
state of mind was like i'm gonna take it
to court cause i got nothing left to
lose at this point if they're gonna
leave me in jail for a year without you
know due process
i'm not trying to rain on this because
this is great news this is really good
news and it's it's definitely an
indication that a lot more acquittals
are coming well here's what i'm curious
about so if we see more acquittals i
wonder which direction that is going to
build political momentum because on the
one hand it could result in people
saying that the entire narrative was
nonsensical and revolting against
democrats as a result or maybe it could
embolden democrats to say these people
are getting away with an insurrection
even though that's complete nonsense and
the judge was appointed by donald trump
yeah there is that but i i still think i
think that people have got this exactly
right they know it was bad that you
shouldn't shouldn't have done it but
they also know that democrats have just
played and played and played this card
until it's it's absolutely maxed out you
know well
i'm sick of it yeah i think i think when
november comes along we have a very good
likelihood a very strong likelihood that
republicans are going to get in the
question is are republicans going to do
anything and i'm not entirely convinced
the january 6 committee will be gone
yeah and then the republican party will
twiddle its thumbs and fall asleep the
republicans get kicked out of office for
not doing what they say they'll do and
democrats get kicked out for doing what
they say they'll do i mean because
republicans if they would actually
follow as trump did in fact if they
would actually deliver on their
conservative promises everything gets
better you know what are some of the
promises that you like that you thought
should have got followed through on
by whom just conservatives in general
that you've noticed well i think for
instance immigration reform you know
maybe we could stop people from pouring
in over the over the border forever you
know i think every country on earth has
a border why don't we
that's that's always a good one i think
cutting back on some of the entitlement
that have driven us so far into debt
that we're essentially a debtor nation
with very little chance of getting
climbing our way out i think that
you know the kinds of things that are
happening in disneyland uh the magical
kingdom which has become even more
magical if you happen to be slightly odd
uh you know i think those are the kinds
of things that a president should
address one of one of the things i
thought was great about trump was that
he fought the culture wars and i think
that that's why he got elected and
that's why he was where he was
can confirm i was uh i went to a bunch
of the trump rallies and the young men
that i met said political correctness
was a huge reason why they were voting
for trump they felt that trump's potty
mouth was a pullback or you know that
would pull everything back to normalcy
in terms of our ability to speak no
question i mean it's just no question
for for 50 years 60 years they've been
telling people in this country their
country stinks their religion is untrue
they're racist they're sexist they you
know everything about them is terrible
and their history is terrible all the
pride that america had for a country
that after all did defeat both soviet
communism and nazism uh
and and was the only republic in the
world when it started was the you know
it actually turned being a republic into
the default position all of that pride
that we had was just absolutely stomped
on for 50 60 years and then they
wondered why did they elect donald trump
they elected donald trump because he
told these people where to go so you
think it was the military industrial
complex the the liberal economic order
the formation 1946 that just just
annihilated that's what i think it is
anyway what do you mean well in 1946
after world war ii they decided we don't
want world war again we're going to set
up this liberal economic order and put
american military apparently are british
military bases a lot of them then the
americans took them set up all these
military bases were like we're the world
police but it seems like they're using
the federal reserve to over print
military military more bombs more blow
up waste money and they destroyed our
economy and our will it's not it's not
it's not the military that destroys our
economy it is the uh entitlements that
cannot be stopped
you know you can't you can't vote the
entitlements out without destroying them
and once the government gives you
something nobody ever gives it back so
though i view this as
putting a band-aid on abandoned and a
band-aid so we get a wound in this
country of some sort like a housing
crisis and then we're like quick what do
we do to heal this wound we put a
band-aid on it mass spending or welfare
welfare programs and it may be a simple
solution to everybody like okay we'll
just you know we've got it we've got a
foo we've got an economic crisis let's
give a stimulus to everybody to keep
them afloat for now slapping a bandit on
the wound then a few weeks later when
the wound starts festering they say you
better slap another bandage over that so
instead of cleaning it off you know
taking the bandage off cleaning the
wound putting a new bandaid on we've
just stacked piles and piles of bandages
on bandages
i'm a little bit i see it in a little
bit more of a sinister light
nobody ever gives anybody anything right
there's no such thing as a free lunch
the word free is actually not english
that doesn't actually refer to anything
that exists except maybe the moon and
the stars you know the best things in
life are free but but nothing is free so
when somebody gives you something you
have to ask what's the price when
somebody gives you you know a free lunch
you ask what are they asking for every
time they give you something it costs
you your freedom oh sure sure sure but
come on that's not true in every case i
mean facebook's free
there we go i think in like the same
with trump's potty mouth i think if the
technocratic spy state wasn't in effect
the potty mouth may have actually
you know brought people back to a state
of sandy or at least a state where they
could they could ruby
i have mixed feelings on the potty mouth
what were we going to say sheamus
you know you you mentioned that when
something's free someone's actually
covertly taking something from you
timcast.com is not free so i'm letting
you guys know it's a plug for things to
be given yeah take your money we'll just
take your money look not you know
patreon.com freedom tooth is it free
either i'm like i know i do like how the
idea of facebook being free was just
absurd everyone laughed at the idea at
the idea because facebook is so awful oh
that's not why
did you see that mark zuckerberg said
his employees endearingly call him the
eye of sauron
no
he thinks that's endearing
worries me a little bit actually yeah
it's amazing that
i i that is he really
there's no way he believes that lack of
self-awareness i think he's spying on
everybody that he work that works for
him but he thinks it's
fine yeah because he's a nice guy he
would never misuse it oh it's terrifying
all right did you ever see terminator 2
you know miles dyson the guy was like
well if i'd known i was going to build
the terminator i'll stop right now
i got to give this i got to give this
shout out and talk about our good
friends over at the young turks because
we have this uh we have this video they
posted back on february 8th and it says
tim poole makes the dumbest january 6
argument yet
oh this is just it feels so good to uh
there's so much to bring up in terms of
cultural politics and politics here that
this exemplifies i'm i'm grateful to be
a part of the story for those that
aren't familiar just to go back to our
previous segment in january i had made
the point that at the capitol many
people were let in the building by the
police that there were no barricades
they had been torn down and people
walked up cops were fanning them in
doors were being opened for them how
could you charge someone with trespass
if they were welcomed into a building
certainly that makes no sense right and
so taking that out of contact some
twitter guy
takes a clip of it the young turks doing
no research
run the clip of it while smack talking
me saying i'm wrong and saying really
dumb poor legal arguments like if
there's broken glass on the ground it's
trespassing i think i think jack may
have said that where they're like i'm
just going to walk over this broken
glass and that means i'm allowed in and
it's like it doesn't mean you're not
allowed in broken glass is not a no
trespassing sign like imagine going to a
mcdonald's there's a broken window it's
like i guess i can't come into
mcdonald's someone broke the window no
that's not how it works
so they run this segment
and uh i am proud to say now that uh we
have been absolutely vindicated proven
right
judge issues the first outright
acquittal of a defendant charged over
january january 6 right we did just
mention this in a previous segment but
here's the best part
i tweeted
how it started how it's going with that
clip from the young turks with the new
article that comes out showing this
guy's been acquitted and i said hey
anna i was right
and their response is anna responded on
twitter as if
the news didn't come out she just
repeated the exact same false premise
on my argument while ignoring the fact
that even her false premise
so so i said the writers are going to go
to jail the violent people go to jail
she's claiming that i'm saying the
writers themselves will be acquitted
because there's no signs which is a
gross exaggeration of my point but
a guy was acquitted this is what they do
so i think it's a really great um
example of what the culture war is
i make an observation based on a legal
theory
we'll see what happens i'm proven right
the young turks double down ignore the
facts and just keep lying well you know
it raises the philosophical question if
you've been insulted by the young turks
have you in fact been insulted
but but you know this is actually the
young turks are just the small version
of this this is happening everywhere the
other day and applebaum of the
washington post
once a fine journalist she used to be an
actually good writer and journalist she
was approached by a freshman from the
university of chicago who said to her
well how do you feel now about the fact
that the joe biden laptop has turned out
to be true after it was kicked off
twitter it was suppressed by the news
and she said oh that's a boring story i
don't care about that so i thought well
here's a story that really does
implicate the president of the united
states in influence peddling and she's
bored she's bored by that of course
they shared bank accounts yeah we've got
more data from the laptop reportedly
coming out soon when she says it was a
boring story she's lying but i know you
know what you're talking about bingo
boring requires glucose to change your
mind cognitive dissonance requires a lot
of energy to override
i don't know if you know this but even
though we know now that the information
on the laptop is is true and legitimate
it wasn't true back then
okay well that explains it so i'm sorry
i'm sorry you were misinformed about
this but it wasn't true at the time
think about the historical record right
so if you pull up stories
from
you know october 2020 you will learn
about russian disinformation
manipulating the united states
this the story today now is that the
laptop is true
there were opinion pieces commentary
analysis subsequent investigations and
this is the track record we get from the
these establishment crony shill
press be it young turks or otherwise the
russiagate stories they want awards for
those things all based off lives
and now we know what's going on well
yeah walter anthony durant you want a
pulitzer for covering up the hall of
tomorrow so here's here's here's here's
the here's what i want you to imagine
this
you look at a history book and they have
a timeline of the donald trump years and
it says in 2016 donald trump colluded
with russia to do this in 2017 donald
trump was investigated for colluding
with russia and then
under the premise that all of those
stories are true which make up the text
of this history book you then get to the
year 2019 2020 and it's like well we now
know that all of the stuff was fake
so how do we go and rewrite the
historical record that they fabricated
you know
well you know but but just just think
about the the old-fashioned idea of a
reporter think about the guy with the
hat the snapping hat and the press card
and his i i was a reporter i was a small
town newspaperman and you would hang
around places just to see if anything
suspicious was happening so if the
councilman walked into the sheriff's
office you immediately thought what's
going on there what is happening here so
here they have a laptop that connects
the president to his dishonest you know
influenced pedaling son that's like i'm
bored i you know what else is on tv is
that you know is netflix on because i
you know i don't want to
i'd like to imagine there was a time
where the laptop story would come out
and every major news organization would
be like guys guys guys get on this we've
got evidence of direct corruption
involving a president instead they were
like
oh no how do we lie to protect him yeah
well in a weird way hunter's off limits
so people were absolutely vicious
towards trump's children and what they
often said is trump's children are only
successful because they had a rich dad
well look at hunter biden he had a rich
dad and he's very unsuccessful and i'm
not saying the man never dealt with
struggle or hardship but why is it that
trump's kids get their heat fell to the
hell to the fire on everything and
biden's kid is a crackhead and you're
not even allowed to discuss it
you look at you look at don jr and he's
like a a prominent personality and
well-adjusted figure and successful
businessman and then he's the bad one
he's the problem hunter biden had to get
his wood yeah like his teeth replaced
his teeth because of his crack addiction
look parmesan cheese addiction yeah no
he was actually remember he was scooping
up parmesan
but my point is more so how the media
treats them
they're like don junior needs to go to
prison and i'm like don junior didn't do
anything hunter biden did things we can
see and they're like oh shut up i know
i'm gonna do the most boring thing in
the world and point out a double
standard here between the left and the
right but just imagine trump's kid with
a crack pipe in their mouth
that would be it that would be it i
think don junior he tweeted if i did
half the things that hunter biden did
i'd be in prison yeah yeah well there's
no question you'd be in jail his dad
told him that and now not only would he
be in prison but donald would be
imprisoned that's the thing
the connection on this laptop is getting
worse and worse the stuff you know china
has a very clever strategy that i think
they call what do they call it hunting
the elites or or elite capture elite
capture that's what they call it they
obviously elite capture joe biden
through his son and i you know is that
illegal probably not but but still i
disagree i think they elite captured joe
biden through joe biden and his son was
the intermediary well there you go which
is why
joe biden used air force ii to fly his
son to china for a private equity deal
hold on tech i mean he was talking about
the big guy he could have been referring
to someone else
have we exhausted all of our resources
in investigating this yet trump is a big
guy exactly trump's bigger than
joe yeah that proves it oh my gosh it's
great it's true you know it's it's funny
how uh
we have the uh the grooming story now
okay groomer
and it's just fascinating
it's almost like the establishment press
left is
it's their their it's
cause and effect is so obvious and
predictable
you know exactly what they're gonna say
how they're gonna say it when they're
gonna say it you could write their
articles for them before they write it
and then publish them to prove a point
but you'd be talking to nobody you know
like i was mentioning with with you know
ann on the young turks even though an
article comes out
actually proving my point was correct
they act like it never happened just to
clarify you were saying that some of the
people that went to the january six
event were just let in and should be not
necessarily charged with trespass but
then they interpreted that as you were
talking about the people that were
breaking windows and stuff as well they
were lying okay so that means and
they're doubling down on that
misinterpretation misinterpretation
willful misinformation
because
well i i think it's fair to say perhaps
that they're making it up because if
they actually watched anything i said
they would have known that i've always
said that the january 6 writers should
go to prison even in the daily beast
smear piece against me they quoted me
saying that january 6 writers should be
in prison so for the young turks to
protect like i've never like i'm saying
the opposite is ridiculous but this is
this is the point
when it comes like the grooming story
when it comes to hunter bite and laptop
we talk about double standards all the
time
this is one of the reasons why i think
it's kind of pointless to give them
quotes or even interact with them
because you know exactly what they're
going to do they'll come out they'll say
you are all fascists then you'll come
out and be like some of these people are
groomers and like oh
they're making up fake definitions of
words now to lie and smear us and it's
like but it's not even a fake definition
that define i mean if you say you should
be able to have private conversations
with someone else's kid about sexuality
and tell them don't tell your parents
you're grooming them
and even worse even worse on national
review they're saying well we shouldn't
say gru it's not technically grooming
you think like there's calling a bill
don't say gay that has nothing to do
with not saying gay can we not at least
fight tough can we not at least play the
game the way the game is played i don't
want to i don't want to go dirty but if
they're going to use phrases that are
catchy and actually turn people against
things why can't we this is exactly you
know what i don't think we should call
them the national review because i
cannot believe that that article was
reviewed before they published it that's
insane or that anybody in the nation is
still listening
the funny thing i'm seeing now from a
lot of people on the left on facebook is
they're arguing the bill in florida
someone posted a meme where it's like in
response to this bill i'm gonna stop
talking to kids about traditional
marriage and heterosexuality and i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna use gendered
pronouns
and i'm like you are now arguing that
the actual position of the conservatives
is the position they don't have
you're i'm confused like you were the
ones who created the narrative that it
banned people talking about gay people
when the conservatives never said that
it was just identity in general
and now you're rev it's it's like
they're mad at themselves there is no
they're arguing themselves to talk to
somebody else's child in kindergarten
about their sexuality there's no excuse
when i was a kid a cop used to come and
visit you in in school and say if
anybody does this call the police you
know the policeman is your friend he
will come and take this bad guy away now
they're actually saying that there are
people on tv saying you know i'm gay and
now i can't talk to children about my
personal life
you know how about that's true teach
them math how about that but also like
am i supposed to cry for that person
like oh no i know but it's not even true
you can still talk about your personal
life if they need to talk about personal
life they need a therapist
to these children right yeah
well so uh i do want to jump to another
story but i'm just curious because
when it comes to the media and the very
obvious predictable nature of the lies
and manipulations i'm curious your
thoughts andrew my attitude's very much
been just ignored at this point because
the moral universes are so disparate
like there's not a single sane rational
human being of of cognitive faculties
who is going to agree that adults should
have sexual conversations with children
in secret
but there's the entirety of the
democratic establishment lying to
maintain that right
what do you think the solution is here
that you know what what do we do today i
think yeah i think you do have to speak
up for the simple reason that people get
afraid they think that more people agree
with them than do and so you know i
worked in hollywood for a long time and
i would walk into a meeting and somebody
would come over to me and say i saw you
on on hannity last night whisper i saw
you on hannity last night and i was like
why are you whispering we're in the
right you know most people in the
country agree with us and the thing is
they can create an atmosphere of
agreement and of being in the majority
that simply isn't the case i mean look
at the fact look at the fact what
happened with disney was this guy bob
chapin he's a conservative he wanted to
take disney out of the politics
a minority of his employees who are
lgbtq
came and yelled at him and he caved
where was the minor where was the
majority sounds like conservatives are
uh have a tendency towards cowardice
yeah yep yep no i was about to say he
sounds like a conservative i think
humans i think humans tend towards
yeah yeah humans seem to be they tend
towards cowardice when they're alone
when they think that's right that's
right yeah big part of it is like you
said speaking up so people know they're
not alone yep i mean you look at what
happened to papa john i'm not surprised
these ceos are like i'll do it i'll do
whatever you say yep absolutely and
that's the other thing they're not going
to get sued by
you know angry conservatives papa john
did nothing wrong
i love that statement yeah that's
correct he was he was uh they'll lie and
they'll they'll cheat they'll steal
they'll manipulate but papa john was on
a phone call and he complained about
racism right he used the word to come he
was a racial slur to complain about the
slur and how someone else had used it no
one cared and we're in a situation now
they've destroyed his life his career
youtube censorship laws is like if you
reference a book from the past that has
a word in it that's now considered
racist you're essentially the algorithm
treats it as if you're the ones making
the racist comment and that's dangerous
for rhetoric for society for free speech
uh i don't you know same thing happened
to john yeah and here's another thing
conservatives do they sit and defend
youtube and facebook
saying well they're they're independent
companies so they can do whatever they
want you don't want the government's uh
you know making rules about them well
yeah i do no actually i do the
government is there it was instituted
among men to protect our god-given
rights the first amendment protects
those rights from the government but the
government actually its job is to
protect our free speech rights when you
have things like google which is
controlling 90 of the information flow
amazon which is selling 90 of the new
books
they can be regulated they can be
essentially regulated to make sure that
everybody gets to speak let's let's you
want to judy i just want to add this
it's kind of hilarious we see this a lot
with conservatives basically just
accepting the left-wing framing so what
lefties will say is you believe in free
market capitalism doesn't that mean you
think any big business should be able to
do whatever they want to at any time and
conservatives go i guess you're i guess
i do believe that sir and then they go
off and they fail to achieve anything
whenever they elect their leaders uh but
you look at the left and they've been
sitting there for years going oh no you
know it's a private business they can do
whatever they want and then as soon as
elon musk buys a significant share of
twitter my goodness we can't these
people are too powerful we can't allow
them to influence the public discourse
with their money let's talk about the
true nature of some of these
organizations we have this story from
timcast.com black lives matter purchased
5.8 million mansion from friend who paid
3.1 million dollars days earlier patrice
cullers described criticism of the
purchase as racist and sexist in an
instagram post
according to a new york magazine report
the national black lives matter group
purchased a six million dollar mansion
in la with donor funds in october 2020
blm took measures to keep the purchase a
secret on wednesday cullers responded to
questions over the cash purchase of the
studio city mansion describing them as
racist and sexist she said that the
author had a proven and very public bias
against me and other black leaders the
expansive estate was purchased by diane
pascal the financial manager for the llc
janaya and patrice consulting the new
york post reported the property was
purchased from televangelists sean and
sherry boltz on october 21 2020 for 3.1
million quote
la county property assessment records
consulted by the post show the value of
the two parcels combined it's one one
house with two buildings at 3.3 million
on july 6 2020 three months before
pascal's purchase
the value nearly doubled after the
purchase of the property on january
24-21 the assessment for the two parcels
shot up to 5.8 pascal told the post he
paid the asking price without
elaborating further within within a week
of the purchase ownership was
transferred to an llc in delaware named
after the property's address public
records show now
i don't know exactly
if this proves anything definitively but
here's what it sounds like at the very
least
there were televangelists who had a 3.3
million dollar property they listed it
for sale this guy buys it for the asking
price which
the the the uh bolts is it was uh what's
the guy's name i want to make sure i get
uh sean bolt said was 3.1 million
about a week later the blm non-profit
bought it for 5.8 where did that 2.7
million dollars go right it seems like
just seems like
it seems like it went to fighting racism
in such a non-profit
pulled a shady deal
to give 2.7 million
to launder it out of a non-profit into
private hands so it is now obfuscated
and used for who knows what i was
waiting for that launder word because
that's what it seems like it does seem
like it sounds like it says just a hint
of you know i'm going to go all the way
on this first of all this blm is a con
game all the way down it is a con game
all the way down they tore this country
apart over the death of a fentanyl
addict who resisted arrest and he the
policing was bad in that story but they
tore the country apart the police don't
kill black people the police are not
prejudiced against black people black
people commit
an inordinate amount let me put it
another way an inordinate amount of the
crime violent crime that is committed is
committed by people who are black
50 of murders i think there's a better
way to put it i think it's uh poor
people
and a lot of a lot of black
neighborhoods tend to be
impoverished maybe maybe but the facts
are the facts
if fifty percent of the country this
seven percent of the country are black
males
it's not that seven percent of the
country are committing fifty percent of
the murders because it's a small number
the majority of black people of course
are not murderers at all it's a small
number of bad guys who are black who are
committing 50 of the crime that puts
police in a certain position that means
you are statistically more suspicious
when you go into a neighborhood and
you're black so you get and it's very
insulting and upsetting for a stand-up
guy who's black to get stopped by the
police for nothing right but it's also
upsetting for a stand-up cop who's also
in the majority to be accused of being
uh racist because there was a bad cop so
so all i'm saying is this is a con game
from the beginning their open plan in
the on their website until they took it
down was a maoist plan to introduce uh
violently introduce socialism and
destroy the american family and destroy
as they call it cisgender sexuality and
they did it through riots it's kind of a
kind and specifically on their website
targeting the family disrupting the
nuclear fields yes but i i i would love
to actually have a deeper like a moral
discussion because i don't i think we
often don't don't go through it um i
mentioned poverty and you mentioned race
but i i don't think you're implying that
um based on race they're committing more
crime just that i don't i don't imply
that i don't think that's true at all i
think the left thinks it's true i think
that's why they want to get rid of
bail and they want to get rid of
policing because they don't they
literally the left does not think black
people can rise above and i thoroughly
believe they can so the the issue i see
you know having grown up in chicago
having lived in new york is that uh i
agree i think the stats are the stats
that come from the fbi um i think it's
tied to poverty and then there's the
issue of historical wealth and systemic
racism now often the right says you know
there isn't systemic racism or we
recently saw with jon stewart and andrew
sullivan sullivan said what systems what
systems
john had a terrible argument i think
andrew performed poorly did you see that
segment they did yeah and so so i would
love to get your thoughts on this you
know the way i see it is
uh crime is tied to poverty and i think
what we end up seeing with like fbi
crime stats it actually generates racist
beliefs that some people believe race is
the component that causes the crime i
think poverty is the component and i
think there are elements of history in
the united states going back to say the
80s see i would i would say culture i i
if poverty caused crime uh wall street
would be an honest place
but poverty does what poverty does is it
limits the kind of crime you could
commit the guy who holds you up in an
alley would happily write a check and
and
you know steal money from a company
without risking his life well then but
he doesn't have that option is it
violent crime is it violent crime yeah
so but but people are sinful they're
broken they're criminal and that is
going to come out everywhere however the
culture black culture has been utterly
destroyed and it was destroyed by great
society programs by the left before the
great society before lyndon johnson's
great society black people were moving
into the middle class
faster than they were afterward they
were warned that the democrats were
warned by a democrat by their own guy
that these programs would foster uh
single-parent homes and destroy the
black family it used to be the 25
percent of black children were born out
of wedlock now it's 75 percent that's
more than when democrats were actually
selling their slaves because all the
slave owners were democrats too they
were selling their slaves down the river
to purposely break up the family it's
worse now they finally broke up the
black family when you go into a prison
a democrat will tell you oh look they're
all black and hispanic therefore it must
be black they're all fatherless every
single one you go down that that prison
cell you are looking at one fatherless
child after another it's culture it and
it and you people are poor and honest
most black people who are poor are also
honest you know they're trying to build
uh jobs they're trying to build a life
and all this but when you have no father
when you have broken homes when each guy
has three different baby mamas and all
the stuff you are going to have more
crime and that's what's happened this is
this has only happened since the 60s
since the you know jason reilly the one
of the much better writers about black
problems in america had a book it was
called please stop helping us
you know and that's what i think the
problem is it makes me wonder about the
democrats position before civil rights
and how their position after civil
rights still perpetuates serious
problems in the black community well
right because i mean the the martin
luther king idea that you should be
judged by the content of your character
not the color of your skin has gone out
the window i want to point something you
saw in in california they were trying to
repeal the civil rights provision from
their constitution do you remember this
because of the uh because the fact that
kept them from doing affirmative action
right right and so i had a conversation
with a friend who was woke and i asked
you do you know the demographics of
california it's yeah it's overwhelmingly
white i think it's like 70 white and i
said and do you believe that there are
towns in california that are 90 99 white
well yes of course of course there are
do you think those towns when this law
passes or when you repeal the civil
rights provision do you think they're
now all of a sudden going to have an
epiphany and recognize that uh they
should treat everyone equally or do you
think that those people because by
virtue of being white they're racist
will be racist towards black people with
impunity because you've repealed the
protections
good question right
so
but but my point there i'm sorry just as
stop helping people right that's the
point they they say we're going to help
you with these these things and they
take away
a provision that was fought long and
hard for civil rights and look at the
way look at the way democrats the left
let's say talk about black people they
say well we want more black people in
school so we in college so we've got to
lower the standards and you think really
how about raising the educational level
of your the crappy schools in their
neighborhoods what would that be like
we're giving them a school choice okay
so they can decide where to send their
kids and obamacare
what is that yes the democrats
continually got that but this is the
problem you know when it comes to
we have a we have a lot of problems you
know give me my i'll give you my
perspective from chicago racial
segregation is the norm in chicago
mostly by choice but still the remnants
of blockbusting and redlining so
redlining is when they said you know the
real estate companies or whatever they
draw out areas where they're like we'll
only move certain people of certain
races you know black people in these
areas near the red line
and so you end up with enclaves there's
actually where i grew up 47th street 47
south when you cross it to the north it
becomes an entirely black community to
the south it's fairly mixed a lot of
polish immigrants
and what happens is the remnants of
those uh policies result in
people wanting to move into areas where
there's people of their own community so
it keeps segregation fairly entrenched
but then you also have laws that were
passed that seemingly do the same thing
i've i've talked about how they had a
latino elotes carts the corn with the
mayo and stuff and they wouldn't let
them come to our neighborhood they
passed a law or whatever banning them
from causing crossing one street just so
happens that one street once you cross
it all the ads are in spanish
so i i think you've got in chicago a
very serious democrat problem i
personally think that they thrive on
racism i absolutely i totally agree they
make it worse because they can weaponize
it to win elections you end up with
chicago being run by democrats for what
now 100 years with with what how many
improvements have have come it's only
gotten worse
it's only gotten worse but you know what
if if i may just
um
people like to gather with their own
this this country we forget what a
revolutionary experiment this country is
what andrew sullivan said to jon stewart
was exactly right i lived out of this
country for seven years this is the
least racist country on earth that
doesn't mean it's not racist it doesn't
mean there aren't racists that doesn't
mean there aren't systems in place that
can be
reformed but this is the only country in
the world
since rome since the roman empire where
we say if you come over you are an
american you come here you're an
american doesn't matter what you'll look
like doesn't matter where you come from
if you look at who is
most successful in american i think in
america i think it's indian-americans
certainly chinese-americans are
successful so it's not color it's not
skin color that's keeping people down
this country is amazing in its ethnic
diversity and when you leave places like
la and chicago that are so largely
segregated like i'm living in a place
now where there are plenty of middle
class black people the couples are all
mixed and all this stuff and you think
like yeah this is what america does it
has always done it there's a special
problem with black people which is that
they everybody else came here to escape
the oppression they alone were oppressed
here and that is a huge difference it
takes a certain amount of grace to
forgive a country for doing that to you
i think they're going to have to
exercise that grace because it's the
only thing that's going to free them
from anger in the past but it's a tough
thing to ask for i think i think the
solution is simple and a lot of these
will people don't want to accept it if
we've already passed laws out we've
outlawed blockbusting and redlining and
other racist overtly racist policies
then the solution at this point becomes
class-based
if
if the left believes that the black
community is disproportionately affected
by historical racism and they're
impoverished because of it lack of
generational wealth then instead of
making race in the law you just say
we're going to provide tax benefits tax
credits to certain families at certain
levels which we do
and then you will disproportionately
benefit black families or
you got to talk about the culture too
this is the thing that gets me about
conservatives here this bothers me about
conservatives
everybody knows in america and this is
still true to this day if you get
married before you have children if you
go to high school if you graduate high
school and then get married and then
have children you probably won't be poor
that's that's just the stats however
however if you grow up without a dad if
your mom is addicted to drugs you know
it's a little harder to do that you know
it's this is the thing that
conservatives forget about like it may
be a little tougher it's it's easier to
do that when you grow up in the suburbs
and you've seen it done you know white
kids listen to rap and hip-hop which i
i'm sorry i think it's got garbage but
white kids listen to it ironically black
kids listen to it and it actually
affects the way they live and their
culture if we don't kids like rap dude
come on no they like it but they but
they listen to it ironically they don't
think oh yes they do because they they
go home and they see oh my my mom and
dad like each other they're not beating
up
but there's white people in in in these
neighborhoods i go from the south of
chicago everyone listen to rabbits i
understand what we're talking about kids
listening to master p i understand that
what we're talking about they weren't
coming home to good moms like my
friend's mom was a heroin addict i i
understand but again we're talking about
generality and statistics
right we're not talking about the the
people who do that we're saying there is
this problem of crime in black
communities that it's not in white i
think you're talking about class
actually because you're talking about
south side chicago and it's the same as
what you're talking about in the black
community so maybe it's just a it's a
community issue i think the skin color
is a false flag that the consciousness
of these people that are like the great
grandchildren of slaves or greater
grandchildren are still
poor and so they're doing crime and then
because you see their skin color you're
like well it's the black skin color
that's
i agree with that
but at the same time you have these
left-wing activists who make it all
about the skin color and as a result of
that they forward policies that actually
do end up keeping the group down as a
whole i would hang out like i lived in
atlanta it's real multicultural i went
down the normal avenue you know with a
mexican community and i would i would
think words to people instead of speak
because i didn't speak the language and
it was i could integrate really nicely
and i understand what you're saying that
there's a black community i i sometimes
i push back on this because i want to
believe that we're all one community as
a species but it's a it's a lot of
hugging cooking home meal made meals a
lot of calling your mom on the phone
like that's not in the white it wasn't
really part of my community growing up i
mean my mom wanted us to have dinner
together but it wasn't that like
hugging love that i sensed in that
community mm-hmm um so maybe i can
concede that they are well you know a
lot of these a lot of these problems
exist for instance in what they now call
hillbilly communities
and
so because it's the same thing it's the
same broken culture and it's the same
poverty except they're white so it's
it's definitely not skin color it's
definitely not about skin color but it
is about cultures that do tend to accrue
in groups of people right so you know if
i put if i put a took 100 people and put
them in a space capsule they would
instantly become a new race right
because they'd sleep with each other and
they would just their children would be
related and whatever happened to them
would affect them so it is culture but
because people tend to gather together
with their kind and sometimes as you say
or are forced together together with
their kind those cultures are going to
look like a surprise let's clarify that
music point you're specifically you're
referring to like the gangsta culture
music not rap as as music
no i i hate it as music but but still
but that's my personal opinion man i
don't understand that i think rap's
great yeah
i know ben also
when i walk down the street when i walk
down the street with my boombox i'm
playing classical music okay
have you heard handlebars by flowbots no
and i'm not going to you are going to
you're going to love it yeah you're
absolutely going to
yeah it's it's it's basically telling a
story of someone growing up and then
eventually becoming a despot you know i
i was in a an uber
going and coming one direction being
driven by a guy one by a girl
both ways they were seeing they were
playing on the radio the same song right
the same uh i don't i don't know if it's
hip-hop or rap whatever it was and the
story was about a a woman being forced
to perform uh fellatio and while they
laughed at her and it was i just wanted
to say like you know this is degrading
it's degrading to listen that's not
indicative of rap that's indicative of a
certain kind of music like a certain a
certain it's indicative of a certain
artist themselves you know what i mean
but if you have a look at madonna you
know i'm on my knees praying or whatever
yeah yeah but if you have a all i'm
saying is if you're listening to that
song and you have a mom and dad who
treat each other nicely that doesn't
mean that much it's ironic it's kind of
it's like watching it's like me watching
a gangster movie i love gangster movies
i'm never going to go out and kneecap
somebody you know but if you are growing
up in a in a dysfunctional house or a
dysfunctional culture a dysfunctional
neighborhood and you're listening to
that it may well become your standard
for how you treat women i think you know
from where i grew up the the
neighborhood i was in was was very like
very multi-racial and that was a lot of
the music everyone listened to yeah so
people weren't going home to uh mom and
dad who were like you know dancing on
date night they were going home to
broken homes so how were the outcomes
in that neighborhood i mean i've had a
couple friends of mine who were white
die of heroin overdoses they almost all
were in gangs and they were white
they're all still very poor and their
lives are some some people have arrested
middle-class living yeah oh definitely
cultural issues for sure yeah and that's
that's i think we definitely agree on
that one my whole thing is just like
rap music
is not all you know just talking about
beating women and doing awful things and
shooting people up like there's rap
music that's very like thoughtful
thought-provoking and modesty
this is this is the only subject on
which i'm probably more conservative
than ben so i i probably shouldn't get
into this
but i think you made a great point about
the brainwashing power of media it's
like massive it's massive and we're on a
new and a new environment a new
horizon and it interacts with culture
because again you know i can play a
violent video game it's not going to
mean a thing to me but if you're playing
it for 12 hours a day and nobody's
taking care of you it actually doesn't
but just just to clarify when you're
referring to rap are you referring to
about the content of the songs
what they depict well i i would also i
also think the music is is simplistic
but i think rock music is simplistic too
so i'm not the right person to talk to
but i do think the degraded lyrics are
are a problem but so that's just an
issue of particular artists like i mean
there there's there's rock music that's
also
simplistic trash too you know with bad
lyrics i agree
yes
i haven't liked the song since like
fifteen hundreds you know when it comes
to how i wanna i like melody it's melody
vocal melody that's what i'm missing
with hip-hop why i don't ever get into
it really you know i i have to tell you
this is absolutely my father was a
fairly famous new york dj and he played
what was called then middle of the road
music which is now called the american
songbook so as a little kid i grew up
listening to frank sinatra and cole
porter gershwin and all this stuff one
day my father who knew music really well
came home and said this new thing has
come out it's amazing this band out of
britain called the beatles and he played
it for me and i was like what eight
years old you know wow and i and i said
are you kidding me she loves you yeah
yeah you're gonna trade cole porter for
that and he said no no this is the new
thing
i'm talking to like a 50 year old man
you know so i i just stayed where i was
i went through the entire 60s listening
to sinatra
i got i got to tell you i agree
um
i listen to music on the radio sometimes
like well now streaming services
autoplay and i'm just like this song has
no meaning behind it at all right it's
just but you know take a look at um
nirvana smells like team's uh teen
spirit
this song is mostly gibberish
i find a lot of rock i found even a lot
of i mean i actually kind of like the
beatles but i found a lot of their songs
incomprehensible i've got two songs
today if you take an lsd that'll help
yeah i'm sure i've got i've got two
songs for you we'll show you um one's
wrapped one's not we'll show you after
the show all right all right you know
but uh and it is mandatory
no i'm sorry and you have to watch star
trek
oh yeah we already did that to michael
malus he is absolutely required
i love star trek michael baldwin
sometimes in hip-hop you get like when
they're talking like this you hear like
the melody and the tone you can kind of
derive a melody out of that like the
voice goes up and down when they're
making their sound
do you like your singing do you like
charlie daniel's band
yeah devil went down to georgia yeah oh
yes songs i love that song i saw a funny
tweet it said when i was little i
thought that the devil in his demon ban
sounded better than you know johnny and
i felt bad about it and i'm like but
anyone who objectively listens
knows that the demon man section of the
song does sound way better
the person who started the salvation
army that's what he said why should the
devil get all the best tunes that was
one of the great lines that song's so
good i love that song devil went down to
georgia i mean i love the future i'm a
joke where it's like wouldn't a silent
solid gold fiddle wave
heavy and sound crummy
let's talk about this story too because
we i want to mention one thing really
quickly about this story because we
strayed from it but i just want to make
a quick point
i think it is poetically beautiful that
the house was purchased from
televangelists because blm they are the
exact same thing it is a modern
iteration they are the holy people who
everyone knows are grifters and hacks
and every normal person rolls their eyes
out but for some reason have a steam and
legitimacy because they claim to be
fighting for a good cause let me let me
pull this story because i think regular
people are waking up
the narrative is breaking
from timcast.com pennsylvania
republicans increase voter registration
shrinking gap in predominantly democrat
state for every republican voter who has
registered as a democrat
four former democrats have become
republicans
four times as many switching the other
direction
i want to i always give a shout out to
scott pressler are you familiar with
scott pressler not really the
persistence on twitter this guy's been
going out registering
all over the place he was cleaning up
cities now this is a guy who gets you
know gets he does the work and partly uh
due to his work and truth be told
there's many other activists who are
working towards voter registration as
well we're now starting to see the tides
shift i don't think the republican party
will be the salvation of anybody unless
people vote in the primaries and they do
kind of what we're seeing up in new
hampshire with the free state project
you see that
getting a bunch of you know populist
america first libertarian-minded people
to run
and then we're going to see some
positive changes but this is massive and
again it's indicative of people saying
we've had enough the economy is in the
gutter we don't like joe biden it's been
a year and already we're seeing this
massive shift and it's also people
snapping out of the media narrative i
want to show you one thing before we all
start diving into this take a look at
this from the generic congressional vote
2022 republicans have a lead of 3.6
points
so we're still a bit uh a bit out take a
look at 2020 the democrats had the lead
in the generic congressional polling
aggregate the entire time ending with a
6.8 lead and republicans still made
powerful gains especially in democrat
strongholds what are we going to see in
november it's going to be
this november is going to be a wipeout i
think unless the only thing that could
stop it and it's not going to happen is
joe biden basically saying uh well you
know i think the environment matters but
the new green deal is finished you know
if he actually turns against the left
because remember like obama biden ran as
a centrist that was the whole point of
joe biden and you know one thing people
forget about obama he was a very popular
guy obviously very charismatic and kind
of likeable guy and and people liked him
every democrat except him was voted out
of office during his term right there
was like two there was like two
democrats still working the rest of them
were you know at a malt shop somewhere
so so that people do not like these
programs but you saw you saw the state
of the union with biden right yeah it
was it was sort of the
we're still hoping to do things of the
union yes because
what's the state of the union campaign
speech but i mean
he talks about border security he says
i'm a capitalist he was he was just he
should actually refund fund the police
that's right yes he did he said we need
to secure the border he's he's he's he's
trying to play
so we're going to cure
the lego chips in the field of dreams
and i mean how stupid does he think well
i guess i guess
itself people switching parties
is proof that people are not stupid
they're waking up and they realize joe
biden is spitting in their faces i i
agree and i i don't even i don't even
know is joe biden running the country i
mean i have no idea but whoever is i
mean really
the aoc bernie sanders wing of the party
is completely in control they believe as
aoc just said on the air she said we've
got to be more uh left-wing because you
know let him let him that's the way i
feel too yeah go for it i think it's the
bankers that are controlling the country
i saw an andrew jackson quote from 1830
where he called the bankers of den of
vipers and then he was attempted they
tried to kill him they shot somebody
shot him two and he broke up the central
bank i i agree to a certain degree right
obviously the federal reserve you know
we all have our problems with but uh i
think what happened to the democrats is
they saw aoc in the rise of the
progressives and they thought we can
wield this power but little did they
realize it was like the one ring and
they would not be able yeah that's right
well biden has always followed the uh
drift of his party during clinton uh he
was kind of conservative i mean he wrote
the uh anti-crime bill that everybody's
complaining about you know so he always
has followed the drift of his party he
is you know they call it leading from
behind i mean leading from your ass
basically but i mean but i mean he has
always followed what where the power in
his party is and right now the energy
the power in his party is from on the
left but not the majority i mean she
follows the party so closely like he
literally steals their backstories when
he talks about it why am i the first
biden to not work in a coal mine
yeah well you got you got you you do got
to give joe biden credit for for one
thing he he's brought a few things to
the white house that we've not seen any
president bring before and it's batacaf
care next no resident and trinidad
i really appreciate the trunan shabbat
of the pressure that he plays game
games he plays
i have to say you guys do that really
well i can't imitate that
it's like it's like another one it's
probably to your credit that you can't
next no resent
a those are easy but trinidad trunan in
the shopping of pressure
of pressure by the way we uh the trinity
shop under pressure we turned it into a
song and made it a cartoon called
biden's greatest hits you guys better go
check that out someone said it's true
indoor dash avatar pressure yes and no i
i do see how you might hear that but i i
listened to that over and over again and
reap repeat trying to transcribe what he
said to figure it out
trinidad and that shape of the pressure
yeah the double in and uh yeah the
trinity
truanesh what true international
something under pressure i think that's
what he was attempting to international
cooperation
like the biden whisperer yeah well we've
been we talked about it before yeah he
does that little whisper it's very
concerning
about him going with the flow is like
that this uh this weird kind of i don't
know how to describe this movement of
like
left
this communist ideologies that are kind
of creepy and it seems like he's giving
it to them like he's just letting it
happen because he feels like that's
where the pressure's coming from is this
we gotta do what the young people want
man i don't know what what he's why but
it seems like he's just folding somebody
told him or he told himself that with a
50 50 split in congress in the senate
certainly but really across the board he
was going to become fdr and that's just
not the way politics works it's not the
way american politics work he does not
have the votes to do the things that he
wanted to do and people didn't want them
done joe manchin you know it's funny joe
manchin actually represents
a more popular point of view than aoc
does i mean if you just count counted
people who agreed checked off what he
manchin believes in they would follow
him but aoc is more popular because
she's pretty she's popular to the press
and she's popular you remember she's
well i'm not saying you're beautiful if
that's what you're asking i was gonna
are the beautiful i was gonna do a
similar joke but i was gonna say uh ian
would you give up all your followers
then i was gonna say it too but i was
like you know what it would be a bad
look to compliment ian they're all gonna
die eventually
you see you see the story that aoc uh
the female says that they failed to
report a million dollars in expenses
that it seems they were funneling money
dark money between two different
organizations run by psychic chakra
barty sounds like a racist sexist thing
to say yeah
this is to me the fascinating thing and
i don't hear anybody talking about this
all these socialists are supported by
the rich and i i don't i wonder does aoc
ever wake up in like in the middle of
the night and think why are the biggest
corporations on earth agreeing with me
i'm a socialist i mean to take their
property away why are they agreeing with
me or does she know that socialism
always serves the rich and the power she
seemed to change about a year and a half
ago something snapped in her brain and
now she's like i i it's weird she's like
on board with that thing it feels like
it it's never changed in a rhetoric
power do you guys ever see the episode
of simpsons where
someone asks homer to listen and he says
you have my undivided attention and then
it zooms into his brain and it's uh it's
it's playing monkey with the symbols
right no no no it's an old cartoon with
the power turtles banging on his chest
i kind of imagine that when i see her
like doing interviews or talking because
she's she said things
and that that are so absurd you'd think
she doesn't have access to a dictionary
or google yeah like when she talked
about capitalism she was like
no one's a capitalist because they're
not rich it's like
those things don't don't connect what do
you talk what are you talking about you
know what google that did you go that
before you said it another one of her
greatest hits is when she was
complaining about the fact that people
say that universal healthcare is going
to cost a lot of money and she said well
why don't people talk about all the
money we're going to save when we don't
have to pay for as many funerals
it's like do you think people stop dying
if we ever know they eat more
oh she said she saved money uh yeah her
district because amazon didn't move
there they're like why are they giving
money to amazon they're not they're
giving them a discount on the taxes they
would pay like so the 30 billion dollars
the city would get and the jobs
right right right so it's like amazon
would instead would pay 27 billion
instead of 30 billion because they're
getting a three billion discount and
she's like but why are we giving them
three billion dollars but here's the
thing so they don't so they don't go to
nationals
is for as many problems as there are
with aoc's thinking socialism being one
of them that's not a unique flaw with
their thinking that's just part of the
socialist ethos this business is only
here exploiting and taking advantage of
our workers the only way we benefit from
them being there is by taking their
money involuntarily so from from their
perspective they really did lose money
on that as absurd as that sounds
but they were either way going to take
money from amazon just a little bit less
but they don't see it that way because
amazon was going to come there and
exploit their workers yeah socialists
never ask themselves where the money
comes from yeah i love i love going on
these posts i'll see on facebook where
it's like
uh
they say landlord isn't a real job or
they say wage labor is theft and so i
asked a few of these socialists some
questions i was like what if the people
who rent my property are paying less
than the cost of maintaining and
upkeeping the property is that theft and
they're like that makes no sense
what do you mean like sometimes people
rent out a property and it will cost
more than the amount they're paying in
rent so who's being robbed now yeah
that's like no no good answer i said
what if i'm paying the employee more
money than they generate for the company
is that theft and they're like that's
not possible
i'm like yeah it's called investment
mm-hmm like
you can involve a project that's making
no money but you're hoping to make money
in the long term so you're giving your
money to somebody who's making no money
for you in the hopes they eventually
will and then you'll get paid back right
they're like well then you're an idiot
that's literally what i was told on
facebook well that's like that's like
when they women demand equal pay for the
same sport and you go like nobody's
watching the sport nobody's watching
women's sports you know it's just like
they will now that men are playing them
but but still you know
and you know you you get paid the money
that you bring in i was uh i actually
knew the people who got uh
the at the x games they used to pay
women 10 of what the men got paid and so
this is the story as it was told to me
because i actually ended up going to the
x games as like a an advisor liaison or
whatever with one of these organizations
so a good friend of mine was one of the
top female skateboarding pros uh for a
while
and what i was told by these people
at the x games they would give i think
it was like thirty thousand dollars
to the first place male winner and the
first place female winner would get
three thousand dollars and when this
group of you know uh parents and
organizers went to disney to espn or
whatever whoever runs it said you're
paying women 10 like that's not fair and
they said look at the stands
how many people are there watching you
guys you don't sell any tickets we can't
pay you money we don't have well after
some clever negotiating and some good pr
tactics eventually they agreed
we're going to pay the same what the
argument was from the organizers is
we have the best female skateboarders in
the world if you can't sell tickets you
have a marketing problem
and so they said you're going to pay the
same you're going to pay and so
eventually they agreed there's a really
interesting backstory behind it i don't
know if it's public so i'll refrain but
that was their mentality i think there's
a decent point there to be honest
well if there is
if if you're gonna invest
in in in a show
and you're saying the going rate for the
top athletes in a division is x
you're investing hoping that you can
figure how to monetize it if you
if you want top athletes
and you're you and and you can't figure
out how to sell those top athletes then
then i'd argue get rid of the division
outright instead of just being like well
that certainly would have been one
answer but i don't understand i mean it
may be there's just less demand yeah
exactly i mean if it's a problem with
marketing why don't these female
skateboarders get together rent a
stadium hire a competent marketer and
make just as much money as the men well
that would require
tens of millions of dollars in
investment they didn't have
potentially but they could start smaller
and they'd still be generating more
income than this business that is just
failing to market them when you come to
the ormonds-based jobs you got to pay
people based on their performance and if
the girls can't jump as high sorry it's
not you're not performing as well but
look at women's tennis women's tennis
makes a ton of money but that's
because women's tennis is almost a
different game i love tennis and women's
tennis is a almost a different game and
in some ways a better game because it's
slower and you can see it more oh that's
so it brings and and they wear those
cute little dresses so that means you
know it brings people in you know no but
that's but that's that's that's
right
everything everything
i i never liked the williams sisters not
because any personal animals but they
were so strong that they kind of
overwhelmed people because i always
liked the slower women's game because
it's just more strategic and more
interesting the the vol the rallies last
longer uh it's it's just more fun
so it makes money women's volleyball too
i've always said this is interesting i
don't know so uh the guy who actually
led the charge for wins tennis in the
80s is the same guy who was leading the
same charge for women's skateboarding so
i think i think there's a there's
there's still an agreement there i think
perhaps they need to create a different
structure and stop trying to just
replicate men's with women and maybe
make something different well i i'm all
for that i think that that is one of the
big mistakes of feminism is they're
always trying to make the women men even
in in how they live their lives like
women start their careers early
because of the feminists say their
careers are important i think why not
have the babies early and then have your
career afterwards it makes a lot more
sense just because men do it one way
doesn't mean women have to do it the
same way i'll tell you man uh
there's this woman i know
she had a kid when she was in her
mid-20s
so this is what what she told me
her and this guy were both doing the
same kind of work
they were working in um like media
production
she ends up having a kid and took off
only a little bit of time to you know
take maternity time off and then raise
the kid but it it disproportionately
held her back because there's an
exponential gain to working non-stop
when you're young
and so you know she was pointing out
that she's now in her 30s and she's half
the distance of the guy who never took
any time off sure but that that that
said i said to that i'm like i don't
know if there's any solution to that
because women literally have babies and
men don't yes and and also maybe she got
something else that men didn't have and
maybe she had a life that she liked
better you know she got to have a kid
yeah and spend time with her kid and
that other guy did it's a nice thing
yeah i think that's the crazy thing
about it that right now
you know
we're telling young girls to be men to
to adopt the masculine role and we're
ign we're sort of ignoring the fact that
having kids is a magical thing it's
beautiful it's wonderful and people take
it for granted and i hate how it's
viewed as some sort of consolation prize
oh you don't have a career but you get
to have a kid as if your career is going
to be more meaningful than creating
human life there are so many people who
are infertile who would love to be able
to have a child and they can't well
they're and we we constantly refer to
this as something that we can just take
for granted in fact we view it as a
demeaning thing oh you think that i
should just have children or you think
this person or these people should just
be having kids like what do you mean
just be having kids that's like the most
incredible thing a person can do let's
trigger the entirety of the uh the
overwhelming majority of millennial
democrat women how many how many women
uh millennial women do you think
secretly would prefer to be stay-at-home
mothers with children i can i can answer
this question most of them
yes
i can i can answer it experientially i i
lived for many years in
a place called montecito which is in
santa barbara possibly one of the
wealthiest communities on earth all of
the women stayed home why because they
could you know i mean that was it they
had they had a complete choice and
people always ask me well why do you
talk about the rich and i say because
they have complete choice you know they
don't have they could have worked and
and i'll tell you something else by the
way just
they were they called them the montecito
moms they ran everything they ran the
town they were i i was a tennis player i
was in locker rooms where guys will say
obnoxious things i never heard a man
this is wife not once i never heard them
spoken of with any anything with like
kind of awe and respect because they
built not just a home life but they
built it's not just having the children
it's creating souls out of those with
those children it's it's a remarkable
thing and those women
actually were you know at the center of
the of the city the education and
formation of children it's so
unbelievably important and it's this
power that stay-at-home mothers have
that they've been told to reject and
you're right that they also serve a very
important function in the community and
it's not as if when they leave to have
corporate careers that is filled by
someone else or a different group of
people it just either isn't done at the
same level or not at all yeah feminists
took the brags of men seriously men were
like we're more important than women
don't they know how much we lie
and now all these years later you've got
men just sitting at home playing video
games all the women are out there making
the money like she bought it dude that's
great yeah so this is of course i'm
being facetious everyone's miserable so
i just did a quick google search this is
interesting in 2015
time reported gallup said 56 of u.s
mothers uh well i don't know if they're
actually saying this is wrong i said who
prefer to stay home over work
if that's what i hope that's the correct
context it's but in 2019 it says
gallup says record high 56 percent of
u.s women prefer working to homemaking
but this is the reason why i said really
because there's social stigma involved
and um you know far be it for me to say
that these women are lying to polls in
secret but we also know about the secret
trump voter that many trump voters lied
to pollsters out of fear or just
distrust
i'm curious if there's a similar effect
with women who would prefer to be at
home with kids or if they really would
just rather be working well the studies
do show that women have gotten
increasingly unhappy uh they used to be
far happier than men they used to be
both far happier and far less happy than
men because women have a wider emotional
range uh but now they're just
more unhappy than men i think a lot of
it's like the birth control and the
water supply and stuff these chemical
these chemicals man i don't know if it's
chemical castration but it's like
changing moods
more estrogen er men have less
testosterone now than they did decades
ago
you can find this dude you can find a
poll for anything yeah so here we go
here's a poll poll finds most working
moms would rather stay home okay well so
gallup says the opposite there's time
difference yeah it's like it's really
hard to know if you pull montecito
you're going to get 98 of women want to
stay home how many people did they pull
2 000 you know we got to figure that out
all i know is i when i was before the
pandemic when i was giving a lot of
speeches at colleges i i used to start
my speech by saying listen
i'm an old guy i'm going to tell you
what i see
young women are miserable when i finish
my speech if i'm wrong get up and tell
me don't be afraid just come up and tell
me you're not miserable you love what's
going on never not once did a woman get
up and say we're not miserable in fact
they often got up and said oh boy are we
it feels like if someone if people are
losing hope for the future that the
women are going to feel it the war the
hardest i think that's a good point
partly because like you were saying they
have a stronger emotional range just in
general being female um for them as a
generalization but they're just like
creators of this they are the one the
anchor of reality and they they see this
nonsense of these dudes screwing around
with each other making war and just like
ignoring you know clean water supplies
like sustainable technology and like
oh man this is i i have to mention my
book the truth and beauty because i want
everybody to buy it but this is one of
the chapters in the book is about the
novel frankenstein which i argue is
about a man usurping the power of women
that they they frequently said and mary
shelley the author actually said it's
about a man usurping the power of god
and i thought no he's not because men
and women can make life you know they
make life out of given material but what
he does is he makes a person without a a
mother
and that's the whole story and by the
end of it the monster as they now call
him the monster says says make me a
woman you know make make a woman for me
make me an eve you made an atom now make
an eve and when he won't do it the guy
becomes a serial killer basically he
just kills every woman he can find and
that's
you know that is a very powerful
expression that that theme you know that
was the first modern science fiction
novel she invented she was 18 years old
19 years old when she wrote it she
invented the genre of science fiction
and that's what science fiction a lot of
times is about so if you look at brave
new world
you know what happens they get rid of
mothers and they just make babies and
machines if you look at the giver uh you
know they relegate motherhood to the
lowest person
my favorite example is the terminator
which is one of my it's actually a great
action film
the first one is one of the great
actions the machines have taken over the
world human beings are trying to fight
back so what do they do they send
somebody back in time to kill the rebel
leader's mother you know and and if you
in the first movie the thing i love
about the first movie is she's not a
muscle man she's not an action hero
she's just a girl she's just a girl
wants to do her hair she wants to go out
and date she wants you know she's just a
girl who wants to have fun but she's the
most important person because she is
going to create not just this life not
just this particular person she's going
to create the person that he becomes
who's willing to fight the machines and
that's a really good point i think
in order for sci-fi to really work what
it has to do is touch on those kinds of
timeless themes and it's a john which is
really predisposed to do so because the
entire juxtaposition is this modern
technology that humanity has just
finally been able to come into contact
with or develop
against our natural instincts which have
been within us for thousands and
thousands of years but so much sci-fi
that you see which is done poorly
completely discounts that and it tries
to hold on to this idea of like the new
socialist man and even though it'll
claim there will be problems with the
new technology it's never anything that
deep i think one of the challenges for a
lot of the woke attempts at film is
they're just
it seems like they're trying to create a
new hero's journey but for women so um a
good example of this is captain marvel
have you seen that movie
uh no i haven't so in a in a typical
hero's journey you you i'm sure you're
totally aware of it i am so basically
you've got uh someone there uh what is
it thrust into adventure aided by magic
you can look at the story of luke
skywalker he's just some regular kids
based on joseph campbell's right story
all of a sudden he is learning about how
his dad was a great jedi knight with
forced powers and he has to learn to use
it he gets a sword and he's on his
adventure and he's just a regular kid
just like you
watching captain marvel was fascinating
because the story there was she was
always powerful but a man was
suppressing her power
and only when she believed in herself
could the power be unleashed
and i'm like
maybe they haven't figured out
maybe it's not possible i don't know
because the story is inherently a
masculine role of a fighter adventurer a
conqueror and it it and maybe that
doesn't work you know what i thought did
work wonder woman did you see wonder
woman yes
i thought that was fantastic
but her uh um the wonderment's character
was very much motherly
and and idealistic he was very girly
yeah
but the idealism versus the realism and
i thought that was actually you know
where well you know where it works it
works in the
uh horror film alien because that is a
film about these monsters that use men
as as mothers they stick their thing in
the guy bursts out of
his belly and basically they feminize
men so the woman in the end has to fight
back and become an action hero but it's
a horror movie yeah
good good one too dude i want to talk
about your book a little bit please
before we go to super chat so it's
called i can barely see her oh the truth
the truth and beauty the truth this is
why i asked you at the beginning of the
show you believe in objective truth of
course oh you're in for it you're in for
he and i have this debate like every
other episode this is this is what this
is about the romantic poets and how they
invented a way of seeing that renews
the way you read the gospels that if you
read the gospels after reading the
romantic poems you will see what jesus
was saying more clearly and one of the
reasons for this is they lived in a time
almost exactly like this one i mean it's
the the relationship is uncanny the
french revolution
they thought it was going to bring
paradise they thought this is it we're
going to get rid of all the priests
we're going to get rid of all the kings
we're going to rewrite the calendar
we're going to change everything we're
going to change language women are not
going to be women anymore marriage is
not going to exist anymore and it all
fell apart it all turned to terror and
world war the napoleonic wars were 12
years of essentially a world war and
only a few people the intellectuals
didn't just like with the fall of the
soviet union the intellectuals didn't
want to let go of this radical dream
that you could transform the world into
a better place and in the aftermath of
the aftermath of this utter destruction
the romantic generation was taxed with
the
job of recreating human consciousness
and one of the things that had fallen
away i think the central thing that had
fallen away was faith this was the first
big explosion of science it brought
faith into question people were actually
becoming atheists for the first time the
first time in in christian europe that
people were actually saying maybe there
is no god or at least there's no
christian christianity or they were
deist or there's something new
and so these poets had to recreate human
consciousness
if you lose god if you lose the idea
that there is this is god and this is
who he is and this is what he tells me
you lose two things you lose yourself
because yourself is not connected to
anything so it's just this kind of thing
floating in space and you lose the idea
of objective truth you lose the idea
that there's some kind of moral truth
so what happens what happens is exactly
what's happening now your inner world
becomes two things at once two
completely contradictory things at once
it becomes meaningless so you say well
we like living in a country where women
have rights but in muslim countries they
live in a place where you have to dress
up in a bag and basically you can't go
outdoors who's to say which is right
which is nonsense we're right i mean
that we are actually morally right or
compare it to say the slave holding
south
was the slave holding south less right
about human rights than the north yes it
was less right it was better not to have
slaves
so that's the first thing they teach
people that their inner life means
nothing their sense of morality means
nothing
on the other hand they teach you that
their inner life is absolutely sovereign
so if in the middle of this conversation
you say oh by the way i'm a woman i now
have to call you a woman or else i'm a
hateful person for not acknowledging the
sovereignty of your inner life right
what these poets came back to the ones i
study anyway
is that your inner life is actually a
collaboration with creation it is
actually the part of creation that
creates uh coleridge was the guy who
came up with that formulation but a lot
of them sort of said the same thing uh
wordsworth called it you called you an
agent of the one great mind
and in reestablishing this connection
with what they called nature but
ultimately became the spirit spiritual
meaning of nature they actually
re-established what jesus was talking
about you know jesus said things like
you can't be creative unless you're a
branch of my vine you can't if the
branch falls off it's not going to
create any fruit it's got to be created
to the source of life
and so when you start to look at the
world as a collaboration of you with
reality which is the only thing that
makes sense come on let's face it i mean
you know if i if i
the only leap of faith you have to take
in life you know people always talk
about the leap of faith i talk talk
about a little step of faith you have to
say to yourself you have to ask yourself
in all honesty not in philosophy class
not in a conversation at two in the
morning where you're drinking with your
friends in all honesty do you believe
that it is better to give a beggar bread
than to kick a child
if if youth can say to me well if
everybody thinks it's right to kick a
child then kicking a child is right
first of all i think you're lying
you don't think that and second of all
if if you will acknowledge that it is
better to give a bigger breath than it
is to kick a child after that you're
done with whether there's objective
truth or not of course there is of
course there is you know there is as i
always tell people you know this is what
i always tell like young people who are
immersed in philosophy is don't believe
what you don't believe
now don't say you believe something
because it it somehow makes sense uh or
you can reason your way to it you can
reason your way to anything you know
reason is not the alt is one of the
tools we use but the reason the book is
called the truth and beauty is because
one of the poets john keats wrote this
beautiful poem which ends with the line
beauty is truth and truth is beauty
that's all you know on earth and all you
need to know and what he was saying was
you are actually a machine built for
recognizing truth as beauty not as
prettiness not like you like red flowers
and i like white flowers
but that shock that you have when you
confront truth when you say oh
holding a slave
is wrong
and that's what beauty is that's that
connection that you have to this thing
that is beyond yourself
is there a step of faith in there yeah
but it's a step of faith that we all
have already taken we just don't want to
acknowledge it why do you think that the
power structures of reality at least as
far back as i can tell have been
deception and murder the people at the
top that have the control are the ones
that are the most deceitful and and are
willing to lie yeah because i think it's
a broken world i mean i think that's the
that's one of the things the other part
of the story of jesus who said you know
i am the way and the truth and the life
as they killed them
and
part of the message i think of that of
the gospels is that you can kill the
truth you will kill the truth
but it doesn't die you know it keeps
coming back you know and the interesting
thing you know one of the interesting
things to me about the passion story the
story of the death of christ is that
there's no real villain in it you can
kind of pick out judas as a betrayer but
he's killed by the church he's killed by
the government he's killed by the people
he's killed by everybody you know and
that is the nature of truth so you're
right it's a broken world and the
powerful and the evil and the deceptive
uh do tend to rise above
but
we know that we know that because we
know what's right and what's wrong liars
have that advantage yeah but but how
would you even know there were bad the
bad guys if there were no objective
truth that's a good point we're talking
about factory farming yesterday and and
i think tim at one point said you know
ian we just eat meat and i was like i
was picturing us in the roman empire and
tim's like you know ian we just have
slaves and it was like i don't think
that
i don't know man it's utilitarian i
don't think that sometimes like you have
to kill a million people to save a
million people like is that right
well well you're absolutely right that
the um how can i put it the analog
between physical life and the and the
moral meaning of life is imperfect it's
broken it's broken i mean
you know
the the famous trolley question do you
uh let the trolley run over five people
uh by accident or do you turn it and do
you let it run over one person by
accident or do you turn it and kill five
people five
there are some questions that can't be
answered they cannot holy be answered
that's the world we live in is it is a
broken world do you think you can do
evil and it's right
well then it wouldn't be evil that
wouldn't be evil yeah that would not
okay i guess then just do you think you
can destroy i mean i personally think
you can destroy and it's right if in
certain situations you need to sometimes
yeah yeah you destroyed nazi germany
things that are things that are
annihilating reality you can destroy
them yes yes and you can kill and it's
right i mean that's why the ten
commandments don't say they don't say
don't kill they say don't murder the
people that i are friends with the
person i destroyed to preserve reality
think that that's evil
but they're but they can be wrong see we
know you know we know we can be wrong
about reality right we know that we
we've fallen in love with somebody and
it turned out no we were just it was
just infatuation and a past uh we know
one type of love yes it ate at least
yeah but we thought it was true love but
it wasn't true love we know that people
held slaves and convinced themselves it
was right it's interesting when you read
their diaries they knew they were wrong
but they convinced themselves they were
right we know you can be wrong so that
means you can be right right if you can
be wrong you can be right the pro the
problem is the truth is that just
because there is such a thing as truth
doesn't mean that you can pound your
palm with your fist and declare what it
is you know jesus didn't do that he told
stories and that's a very complicated
way socrates just ask questions you know
the people who actually understand that
there is such a thing as truth and they
are the two people i think on which our
civilization is based and they're the
two people who both lived in a time of
relativism and declared there was such a
thing as truth but neither of them said
and the truth is this i thought
einstein's christ
there was a god well christ said he was
the way in the truth he said that but
that's a very complex thing to say right
i mean but i mean the truth is a person
it's jesus christ that's right that's
right and then there are also certainly
like if you love me keep my commandments
which means these are things that are
right and wrong yes but but the
commandments are interesting because the
commandments are almost always negative
and one of the questions my book asks is
once you do the negative things what's
the positive thing you're supposed to do
because a lot of people never get to
that point they think like oh you know
i'm i'm not cheating on my wife i'm a
christian you know i'm not drinking too
much on my christmas you know you think
like okay but
would would the king of heaven and earth
suffer death just to tell me not to
cheat on my wife you know my wife tells
me not to cheat on her i don't actually
need god
to tell me that you know there must be
something more that he was trying to
tell us and i think he was trying to
tell us that there is a way for us to
collaborate with reality that is
incredibly beautiful and is happening to
it happens to each of us all the time
i want to ask
why is it
do you think
that among many uh secular atheist types
they they almost have a desire to
believe in in random nothingness
yeah well because it it they think it's
going to give them power
they think it's going to make them free
and it does it always does exactly the
opposite i mean that is that's kind of
you know
to use the word to say the word out loud
that's kind of it's kind of satanic that
there are certain things that offer you
power anger makes you feel powerful uh
you know that rage you feel against
people thinking that you're totally free
thinking that i can i can change my sex
i just have to announce it and i've
changed my sex that sounds like power
but it actually enslaves you to to uh
elaborate a little bit further is you
know i had a conversation recently with
someone who said that they were just a
wet robot that's all they were yes yes
and i'm like but
why would you
what makes you i i don't know understand
why someone would believe that the the
idea that i had was
you know for me i personally feel a soul
or something akin to this idea or
concept of an inner being a self there's
something within me and uh i personally
feel and have
personally experienced some kind of i
guess you can say a connection to god or
something like that
if someone doesn't have that i don't
believe they're lying to me i just said
maybe they don't have a soul yeah maybe
they don't have a connection although
there is
it is obvious that some people are
better at this they are born for it and
jesus says one of the most painful
things he says is to those who have even
more will be given to those who have not
even what they have will be taken away
and i think that that's what he's
talking about that some people don't
feel that connection and some people
just do what what what really really
trips me out more than you know anything
in term like
let me just put it this way having these
conversations with like michael malus
about dmt the the breaking through the
veil
meeting other people on the other side
and those conversations i think at the
very least open the door to someone
should at least be agnostic i mean
you've heard these conversations i'd
imagine you know joe rogan talks about
it we were talking to to michael malus
and he was telling us stories of meeting
people on the other side communicating
and then coming back and being like wow
how did we share these thoughts and i'm
like well whatever it is i don't know
but it certainly suggests there's
something beyond us right and it's
something weird actually i i knew a
young woman who was a socialist and a
materialist and she was about 40 i guess
and she died and came back and i said
wow did you experience anything she said
yeah i actually you know left my body
and i saw the doctors in the room and i
and i said so has that changed your mind
no
you go like okay you know i mean that's
like you knock yourself out i think it
was a aquinas who said to the uh the
believer no explanation is necessary for
the non-believer no explanation is
possible
yes yes i mean that's that i i wrote in
my memoir that there's if you if you
believe uh that
everything is proof if you don't believe
no proof can be enough i think let's
start to look at plasma clouds i mean
it's almost undeniable that there's
intelligence involved in the movement of
plasma fields
well that's that is another thing i mean
the science actually you know it made
sense for there to be atheist after
newton you know because you could kind
of extrapolate oh everything's a machine
but it all turned out to be much weirder
than newton said and now really there's
a wonderful book about this called the
return of the god hypothesis or really
it's not you know the kind of the title
sounds like it's a
hippy dippy like religious thing but
it's a real scientific book about
why scientists are now saying you know
there actually are there actually is
evidence of an intelligence
behind creation to me that's the only
thing that makes sense well i like to
simplify it um or at least explain it in
sort of a way that i think most people
who are secular liberal type should
understand is
if uh you know we build computers
computers act based on the rules that
exist in reality and they and they you
know they imitate intelligence or at
least we're producing artificial
intelligence then for me
i don't believe that the computers we've
we've built are the the the final point
at which computers can ever come to uh
but a better way to look at is the human
mind if you're just a wet robot well
then certainly the human brain isn't the
end-all be-all of computational power
within a living being certainly there is
the probability based on the expanse of
the universe and our scientific
understanding that there will be a more
powerful intellect that exists beyond
human comprehension it's interesting
when you you know uh c.s lewis had this
great line he said even a determinist
will ask you if you will please pass the
salt meaning he acknowledges it
that you have free will we all know we
have free will and we get talked out of
it uh yeah and and that would mean our
entire experience of life is is
deception and one of the things these
poets were trying to say is you know
your in interior experience can be
deceptive but the very fact that it can
be deceptive tells you that it can also
be right and that there is a truth that
can be deceiving you about i think that
the chemicals like the bacteria that
live on the food you eat mind control us
they they tell you you want more of that
so you get these cravings but when you
fast you you strip away the lies and
like the fakeness of being told the
wrong thing and you start to see or at
least
experience the
the real
i i don't know how to describe it with
human words yeah it's an energy field
well i mean it is it is we've all been
in a kind of haze of unknowing and
delusion everybody's had that experience
i mean
a pretty girl only has to sit down next
to you for you to experience some of it
you know to just be go into this kind of
haze of of lust basically
so we all know that we can come out of
that and be more realistic
so we must be moving towards something
more real you know i just had a thought
i was wondering you know i wonder if
people who um view themselves as
atheists or or what what percentage of
atheists have meditated or prayed i
would imagine it'd be relatively low in
terms of praying maybe a little bit
higher in terms of meditation but i'm
wondering if a lot of people just don't
try to have an internal experience or
something
i
just a thought because i kind of feel
like i completely agree with this that
yeah yeah you know
i i grew up catholic uh briefly and my
family left the church and i've met a
whole bunch of different people from all
walks of life from you know anarcho-punk
atheist types to anarcho-punk catholics
and they've you know i i
i've heard a lot of interesting thoughts
but the one thing that that really uh
stuck with me is
there was uh in terms of people who are
spiritual agnostic or believed outright
is that there was a desire to discover
more
and for a lot of the atheists it's sort
of
it's it's kind of a
tendency towards i don't want to i'm not
trying to paint every atheist this way
was
sort of determinist sort of absolute
sort of we aren't going to know so i
don't know what i can say to that as
opposed to like you know the crazy
people i know who go on spirit quests
and go down to south america do
ayahuasca and yeah the people who are
seeking answers and trying to find
things tend to be more spiritual or
believe in my experience well you know
antonin scalia the supreme court justice
told a great story about right outside
of washington in a church there was a
statue of the virgin mary that began to
bleed or cry i can't remember what it
was and he said no reporter went out to
cover this story and that tell i think
that tells you something i think you
know i did a a video a long time ago
called find god in 90 days i care 60
days whatever and the idea was just just
go into a room by yourself where you can
pray out loud for 15 minutes every day
and see if you get an answer you know
because you will if you clear your mind
i told my i had a bunch of lies and
secrets that i kept my whole life when i
was 26 i decided what would jesus do in
this with this technology he'd be honest
so i started making youtube videos and
telling people my secrets about my past
and it started to clear up my thoughts
and i no longer got interrupted by
randomness i could ask questions to my
consciousness and it would respond and
now with fasting it does it even more
clear that's really interesting i that
that is that's a very first of all a
very brave thing to do but it is also
it's just incredibly true that if you
let go of the lies i mean one of the
things about christianity is the first
thing that happens i converted at the
age of 50. so i'm not you know i'm
telling you something that really
happens is that you suddenly think like
oh i get it i'm a worm you know i'm a
schmuck and then you're free you know
you're free you you're forgiven you're
done you got it and and you have that
exact same kind of experience of
liberation yeah there was a uh i look
back on this moment in my life as as
just perfectly ironic or or hilarious
when i was a teenager i read that famous
quote the only thing we know is that we
know nothing
or who's that socrates and i remember
thinking that and i'm a teenager and i'm
like that's the stupidest thing
and i was like i know tons of stuff and
then i think i was like 10 years later
i'm 25 and i'm like
no truer statement
shout out to socrates
being an arrogant young kid you know and
then thinking i was so smart and this
great thinker was so dumb that's what it
always i when it's every now and again
i'd go to college and people would
protest and they'd scream and i just
think you know you don't know anything
what are you screaming about you know
like you know i may be wrong but you
have no way of knowing well this is just
too young you know i'll tell you but and
we'll jump into super chats in a second
like we'll get to super chats it's just
when we have people on this show and
i'll say something passively about say
you know joe biden's illicit dealings in
ukraine and they'll say oh that's not
true and then i'll be like
allow me to go through every story every
name every journalist and i'm like did
you even google this and they're like no
i'm like you don't even know but you've
taken a hard stance on this
that's just weird to me but we do got to
go to can i just mention one more thing
yeah um so
we our conversation got
interrupted or disjointed i think there
are some things on the just the ten
commandments in the nature of
spirituality that we might disagree
about and can flesh out more hopefully
on the after show because i think that
would be a fascinating discussion i'm
really enjoying hearing you talking
about this and the way you yeah yourself
on it we'll go deeper i will i will of
course have to burn you at the stake no
yeah understandable i i get how it goes
but you know it's worth a good
conversation related to the salem
witchcraft the putnam's and putnam i
think she's in my answer are you saying
we are
yes we're gonna go to super chats ladies
and gentlemen if you have not already
you must smash that like button we
implore you do it for ian thank you
smash the like button for him otherwise
he gets uh he cries and sheamus gets him
i'm gonna bring him out
punch the walls because ian's crying
keeps me up it's just uh but don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have a members only segment up at 11 p.m
for all of you you won't want to miss it
we're going to talk about some crazy
stuff for sure life the universe the
secrets and all that but let's read some
super chats here we go
christopher blakely says have ian check
out
boraphine oh yeah love your show watch
everything thanks guys it's like a boron
graphene uh compound of some sort and
here is so massively awesome we got
important one from pirate taurus he says
i saw my first chicken party today
amazing
so uh you saw the chicken i did i was
very impressed with the chicken salad
actually saw the chicken's having sex
which was probably the highlight the
highlight of my week right
well it doesn't it you know it doesn't
seem consensual
so yeah
yeah oh i'm not going to make chicken
jokes but i could i should prefer
borphenes and allotrope of boron i don't
think graphene is involved carbon's
involved at all so uh
we have 20 000 subscribers of our
chicken city it's been a month
people love watching chickens and pets
people say they turn it on for their
cats and their dogs when they're out and
the animals just love watching the
chickens oh that's awesome so we have a
meter
and when people give five dollar super
chats treats fall down from the sky egg
we call it make drops treats once the
meter hits a hundred dollars
it will queue on every five minutes it
will run a check if the meter has
reached a hundred dollars it plays dance
music and a bunch of treats start
pouring out and it's it screams chicken
party
that's great we uh uh
yeah i was talking to the guys with the
daily wire and i said look we do really
stupid things here over at tim cass like
i don't think any traditional media
business would
do this but we're gonna we're working on
a commercial
that i want to put on the networks and i
i genuinely i i plan to have it run on
tucker carlson and i think i'm i'm i've
already talked to the ad people over
tucker in the past and they're they're
they said yeah absolutely you know it's
just you pay for it we run the ad as
long as the legitimate business we'll do
it so uh chicken city makes money it's
our second uh uh highest grossing show
now
so
is it really i mean because people give
money for treats in terms of like
viewership and everything it's
relatively low right but uh it's a it's
a business item so we can we can have
you know pop culture crisis is doing
really really well and getting tons of
views but it's all ad revenue based so
maybe we should give them some treats oh
yeah we'll do it we'll do a pop culture
live stream and we'll put the egg
i think actually that would be funny to
do as long as brett gets up on the desk
and dances that's great but it can't be
meal worms that fall down it's got to be
like reese's pieces yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's raining candy on breath that'll be
healthy yeah all right let's read some
more
all right
mevro saint john says as a member of the
lds church utah being left-leaning is
not at all surprising they are the most
left-leaning religious group look into
it wow wow yeah
nos says hey it's my birthday today i'm
officially 21. can i get a happy
birthday love you guys all you guys are
heroes to me happy birthday nos
happy birthday happy happy birthday
big day big year for birthdays yeah i
say that every year everyone's here this
year it's crazy
the wrong writer says
love graph ian's freudian slip last
night he said meta virgins also shout
out to mythical vigilante he got me
addicted to your show he's a good
musician check out his music i said meta
versions
meta virgins is also very very funny
all right raymond g stanley jr says
sheamus the first irish he him to be on
irl props right those are my pronouns
thank you for respecting them appreciate
it
christina h says daily wire please make
the novel one second after into a movie
god bless
what is that about you i don't know what
i don't know
one second after
what is this sam spade says i joined
klavanon
and feel better than i have in years you
can too by the truth and beauty save the
clavin that's right
ryan crabtree says ian read ein rand
non-fiction and other objectivists such
as leonard pakoff learn to distinguish
between the metaphysical and the
man-made you're saying no andrew
don't do it why would you think not to
do it because i think ayn rand was
well i really think she was a psychopath
in some ways but i think she was
she was
based
yeah no she was a terrible novelist and
and b her philosophy is ridiculous make
me want to read it even though when i
was in my life
i was in my libertarian phase and i
purchased a copy of atlas drug i just
couldn't do it i've noticed that reading
and listening they write information on
my brain differently i feel like when i
read something it it like directly
interfaces my brain with it when i'm
listening i can kind of shut it out
easier
yeah i guess so i i actually i feel like
i remember things when i listen a little
better uh but i love to read i mean i
just love that
because it's just direct communication
with your head you know yeah all right
cyrus nursial says hey timcast was
trying to find the spin the ufo email
but couldn't find it anywhere i've been
in it for 13 years and the dod is active
duty government civilian and contractor
but i would like to send in my resume if
possible keep up the good work was it
spin the ufo gmail.com that's correct i
have a lead on this write this down one
second after uh this is about a man
struggling to save his family and his
small north carolina town after america
loses a war oh interesting
sends america back to the dark ages all
right ac gaming says i think elon musk
possibly bought stakes in twitter based
on him integrating it with neuralink my
worry is governments will get their
hands involved and leave backdoors to
paralyze you in scenarios in people
becoming fugitive what are your guys
thoughts on this read the software code
are you going to join the metaverse
you're going to get the neurolink
implant and plug your brain
good games i might go on you know well
you know you know what i actually
i'm not against the metaverse as a tool
you know just like i'm not against the
internet as a tool but i think
everything can be used badly
yeah and getting getting an implant to
like plug your brain yes and also being
on it for more than like a half hour at
that you know i mean i just the idea
that you're going to live on this thing
is is bad but if but if you could what's
your what's your favorite fictional
what's your favorite kind of fiction
genre the novel you know
oh you oh sci-fi fantasy so probably it
would probably probably be mysteries you
know if you could plug in your brain and
be the detective in the mystery actually
experiencing the crime and the villains
and yes would you do it i would do it
for half an hour you know yeah because
i'd want to come back to real life
because i think real life is really
rewarding but i mean would you would you
get the surgically implanted port so
that you could do it it's hard for me to
imagine doing that you know i've never i
remember taking a friend to get a a
minor piece of plastic surgery and
thinking i will never get elective
surgery right i agree i i think in order
for it to become feasible they'll need
wireless yeah of some sort sure i put a
plug in my ear you know like you put on
a cap and then it broadcasts into your
brain but i i unless we we start
i just i don't see surgical anything
working for people because people don't
like surgery not mainstream yeah it'll
be for people that have already like
spinal injuries and stuff that are
willing to see if they can learn how to
walk again yeah
i mean maybe when they get to the point
where neural link can actually put you
in a
universe and you can be a superhero
people might be willing to do it i i
don't know why you would do that if it's
not real like i feel the same way about
ayahuasca by the way if like you can
take a drug that makes you see mickey
mouse that doesn't mean mickey mouse is
real if you take a drug that makes you
see god
why would that be an experience i think
of it as like tuning the brain frequency
to see what's already there
but but are you how do you know you are
i mean i don't know but that's how i
what it seems like okay um i'm not sure
the reason i said free the software code
was because if we can free the software
code of twitter and of the neural net uh
tool then you can watch what it's doing
algorithmically uh free software code
being ag pl3 as the license interesting
and then if people want to take it make
a better version that'll also be agpl3
you'll be able to witness it so when the
government comes in and tries to steal
data you'll see the algorithm
where it's giving the data and what's
being given that's that's that's an
interesting idea yeah all right richard
says tim you often say people are
cowards clavin came out as conservative
and lost millions from hollywood clavin
didn't have support then but with daily
wire and tim cast coming together y'all
are the future
well we've been talking daily wire about
um shows
uh we had uh dallas sonier sonja
and uh uh he was like we'd love to do
some kind of show with you guys because
it would be such a powerful you know
thing and i'm like we got a bunch of
ideas for shows we're trying to make
yeah that'd be absolutely fantastic
andrew what was it like breaking out of
hollywood what was that like i i was
thrown out of all of that
breaking out
no i i you know i
my
my salary my income went from high six
and seven figures to nothing almost
overnight when i came out as a
conservative uh i mean that my phone
stopped ringing like that and and you
know i was not a big deal but i was
selling scripts routinely and if you
sell two scripts three scripts a year
which i sometimes did you're making a
lot of dough you know and it's just i
don't know i it never funnily enough
didn't bother me i mean it obviously
bothered me economically you know i had
to sell my house and things like that
but it didn't bother me emotionally
because i thought like i'm not going to
live
my life not saying what i mean because
some fat jackass
doesn't like it you know what kind of
life would that be you know you should
write that for the universe story i i
told you yeah now you gave it to me i'm
stealing it of course you know oh no i
was writing it during the show
i looked over his shoulder there's like
a lot of grammatical errors i can't
believe that this guy was in hollywood
for so long are you sure it was the
conservative
[Laughter]
all right here we go
colin stevens says tim thomas so will
vehemently disagrees about systemic
racism existing perhaps you should get
him on to have this conversation
oh would it not be amazing yeah i mean
he is the smartest man in the country
but but i'll clarify my point because i
think there may be a semantic um
issue
when i say systemic racism what i'm
referring to is the
because of things like blockbusting and
redlining you now have deeply
impoverished areas in chicago
that makes it very difficult for the
people who live there to transfer wealth
to their kids because homeownership is
one of the principal ways by which the
middle class transfers wealth to their
children yeah but but why is it that
other i mean everybody who came here
got nailed in some way i mean you know
well this is going until the 80s right
so i'm not saying that i'm actually not
sure of that you know the new york times
well the new york times
oddly enough did a piece about how some
of the what was called redlining was
actually just economic reality like
people didn't want to give loans to
people who weren't going to pay them
back blockbusting was happening until
the 80s it was until it was made illegal
you know blockbusting was yeah that's
right
really messed up yeah uh and and the
reality is
well listen nobody's going to argue
about the there was racism in this
country right right but the market's
still racist
so
let me ask you i mean uh in all honesty
if if a black family moved into a
neighborhood what is your expectation of
property well wait
wait a minute though you should read
helen andrews on this he wrote a book
called boomers is really interesting on
this if a black doctor moved into my
neighborhood i don't think anybody would
notice you know i mean i literally think
that would be like you know come on over
you know for lunch
if if like you know a bad guy moved in
or somebody who was not did not fit in
that neighborhood economically or in
terms of class then you'd have a problem
i mean people you know
helen's uh argument is that there was no
white flight there was flight from crime
and a lot of times you know when when
neighborhoods changed over they became
more criminal and people left you know
so i don't i don't know i like like i
said i
if a you know sidney poitier moves in
next door is anybody going to leave well
so so my view on this is it's a
class-based issue today uh-huh it was
racial no question no question
but so when i when i refer to systemic
racism i just mean that uh
in the past several decades they were
overtly racist policies that made it
harder for the black community and and
other racial minorities to transfer
wealth and now they're
disproportionately impoverished based on
those things even though it's a class
issue but again that happened to other
races and
absolutely once once it was stopped they
rose very quickly i i really do believe
if if the democrats would just stop
helping black people they would get it i
don't know if they're trying to help
no no no i genuinely i mean look being
from chicago seeing that democrat rule
has done it's been a disaster
unemployment insurance is insane it you
can't get a job or you lose it right so
it's enticing
that's crazy
and you know that was the other thing
clinton's welfare reform really was
great it actually helped people get jobs
and then obama gutted it you know robbie
hammer says come on tim being poor isn't
an excuse to commit violent crime
against another human it is 100 a
cultural issue andrew was spot on
i don't disagree um i think if people
are growing up in poor broken
communities they're more likely to have
a bad culture than people who are
growing up yeah that's right that's
absolutely true yeah so you know i i
think there's great nuance to this but i
certainly think culture plays a very
serious role for sure
all right
let's grab some more super chats
let's see sliver bach
slips says i think there's systemic
racism in old unused laws not our
practice now we still have laws that
allow loving on goats and men are
allowed to hit their wives sundays on
the courthouse steps is that true
they can't be true and maybe you know i
just learned today that in virginia
uh two years ago they made it legal to
have sex before marriage
so some laws are on the books that
nobody pays attention to well you know
i've often said the laws don't matter
what matters is cultural enforcement
that's right that's right um the best
example that i think people should
really ponder on is
in new york city gender identity is is
uh defined as self-expression in this
the actual laws which means your
self-expression could be a furry right
but i was i was i was told by civil
rights lawyers three different ones when
i investigated this that if you tried
claiming
a furry as your identity and you wore
the outfit and you used the name you'd
be laughed out of the courtroom
but i said then then what's if the law
says you can't be discriminated based on
the clothes you wear the name you give
yourself or your self-expression why is
it different different for a furry and a
transgender person and they said because
most people understand what gender
dysphoria is in a trans person and
furries would not be considered serious
and i said that's a cultural issue not a
legal distinction right so it's really
about cultural enforcement and what the
what our culture is willing to tell us
that's one of the problems like when the
supreme court had that ruling that laws
protecting people according to sex
against sex discrimination covered
transgenderism because if you walk into
work in a dress you're essentially being
penalized for being a man
that to me was absurd that was not what
they meant when they wrote the law you
know you may want to make that law but
it's still not what they meant cigars
and sig arms says let's stop pretending
that conservatives are blameless on the
problem of black men filling our prisons
they have consistently refused to call
out bad cops push for criminal justice
reform and cheer on police brutality
nah you disagree no yeah i mean nobody
cheers on police brutality i think i
think the problem is the media lies so
often about all these police brutality
stories it's more that the conservatives
just don't care to believe it anymore
yeah i mean like you know i i do think
i i do think that when you're a bad guy
and you resist arrest and you get killed
it's true that even if the cop did it
wrong which i do i think happened with
uh
floyd i i still think i i don't have
that much sympathy for you you're still
a guy who held a gun to a pregnant woman
and while your friends ransacked her
house you know you're not my favorite
guy i'm sorry you know honestly i've
done bad cops i i think the the the
issue for me is these cities have a
bunch of democrats who vote for
democrats who appoint democrat police
leadership who are crooked and corrupt
and then the democrats complain about
the people that they voted for
yeah well you know you don't hear about
these these these problems in mostly
conservative rural areas it is amazing
that in san francisco which i live where
i lived many many years ago and was one
of the most beautiful cities i've ever
been in it's now a hell hole it's
amazing to me a that republicans don't
run mount a campaign that would appeal
to san franciscans and b that san
franciscans don't say you know what we
keep electing the same party and things
get worse and worse and worse maybe we
should change parties there's a stigma
that republicans are anti-gay well how
where did that come from you know it's
like is it seeded propaganda or did they
used to be no i think it and no i think
the the the
uh
after reagan there was a coalition of
conservatives some of whom were
evangelical and they were very strongly
anti-gay you know they very strongly
felt that this was a bad thing uh
biblically and they couldn't defend it
in law they couldn't say to themselves
well this may be a sin but that's
between them and god or you know they
just couldn't get there
it was very very much
you know in keeping with
their their religion and their way of
life
i remember when i first became a
conservative which is now back around
2000 you know and andrew breitbart said
to me i want you to become part of this
movement and i said i'm going to become
part of the movement but i don't want to
hear about the gay stuff because we're
wrong you know we're just wrong about it
you've got to let people live their
lives
and just i don't know if i can say on
that what how much i can say on the air
here like what your what your standards
and practices are but andrew's response
was basically yeah i i want there to be
more pro-american gay pornography
[Laughter]
yeah i would disagree i think that what
basically happened is you had a lot of
christian conservatives not just
christian conservatives but most of the
country at the time which was saying
that marriage is defined as between a
man and a woman and federally funded
marriage contract shouldn't change that
definition because it's not within the
purview of the government and so what
the left said as a result of that in
response to that was the only
explanation for that attitude is hating
gay people
does that too all right nick says andrew
should listen to tom mcdonald especially
in god we trust
have you ever heard tommy donald no has
he ever has he ever listened to frank
sinatra
but are you familiar with mcdonald's no
oh you you regardless of the music you
get you'd love his message okay well i'm
sure
listen i love zubi you know those would
be the greatest you know i mean who
doesn't can't love that guy know the
time i have a song called facts don't
care about your feelings i think so
oh yes i did hear that yeah i did yeah
we all gotta laugh but does does he rap
as fast as ben shapiro would on that
track
i gotta be honest i think ben could
probably rap faster than most rappers
has anybody
this is actually why everyone should be
everyone's mad at ben shapiro for not
liking hip-hop they should be very glad
because he would dominate the game the
best freestyle rapper and he could do
all playing the violin
[Laughter]
crush
all right
jacob manning says i'm not one to give
away my hard-earned money but tim since
you brought the other half of the first
two people that woke him to reality i'll
make an exception thank you both for
what you do and helping me laugh my way
through all through the fall of the
republic well thank you very much jacob
i really appreciate it
dylan says classic rep has a lot of
libertarian messaging
it does absolutely
that's true hey you know trump used to
be a hero of rappers i mean he was in a
lot of songs you know jt reed says
andrew have you heard tom mcdonald's
song blame the rappers it goes into how
modern rap is responsible for the
degeneration of today's youth adam
calhoun raps about how hard work got him
got him to his success ryan upchurch
raps about his life in tennessee
very good stuff
all right not really me says charlie
daniel's late 70s long-haired country
boy
you're all right
glenn says the best love song do you
remember love from macross the movie do
you remember love not familiar with it
man is everybody just saying the songs
they really like
i guess that's what's going on what's
the best song super chatter right now
yeah tell us yeah super get the best
song give us money to say what the best
song is yes
if you can afford it
all right what is this what is this um
simulated dave says tim if you're
serious about dw entertainment envy i'd
love to discuss my short film crit from
2020 exploring the signatories of the
polanski edition hoping to encourage
conviction in withholding cash from
hollywood interesting you can always
email spin the ufo gmail.com it's the
easiest way for like this one's
specifically for people who watching the
show and there's something specific we
want to message like on our website we
have emails you can you can message but
that's that's the one that during the
show we remember to check out
orange red says if you like andrew
subscribe to the daily wire we are big
fans of the daily wire that's correct
i'm excited about the work they're doing
all right gabe says sorry about my name
i don't understand why
uh oh oh i see i didn't read his whole
name wow that's too bad that's pretty
bad why do you guys
his last name is itch
why do you guys think that actual good
trustworthy people who could win
elections joe rogan jordan peterson etc
won't run the it's too much criticism
argument is selfish to me it in such an
important time um i think for like
jordan peterson he's canadian
right i mean i guess he could run into
do whatever i want i actually heard him
say he thought he could do more good
outside of that system exactly that's
what i was going to say i mean do you
really think joe rogan or jordan
peterson would do more good for the
world in some political position think
about how much they're helping people
right now doing what they're currently
doing they're clearly very good at it
why would you take them and shoehorn
them into some position that the most
pathetic people in our society usually
fill and also you know actually doing
politics is a skill you know it doesn't
mean they just because like they're
brilliant people doesn't mean they have
it yeah i mean i would people have asked
me why don't you run for something i'm
the last person who should run for
something you know like i can't balance
my checkbook if i weren't married i'd be
living in a dumpster you know
all right dwight says if god created the
universe he would have to exist outside
it those seeking proof assume that he
would be bound by the laws of the
universe computer programmers aren't
limited by their own code brilliant
point but god is not limited so god
could exist within the universe it
created and i don't like calling he
either because i think that's patriarchy
no no no
and here we go no he isn't there's not
enough time left to argue with that's
talking about
he is he um and it has a long way his
preferred pronouns you have to let's
let's actually say this for the after
show yeah we'll have a great
conversation i think it'll be fun and
we'll we'll have more time so let's just
read a few more of these super chats and
name some of the best songs um
m1969 says best song is the greatest
show on earth by night wish thank you
totally wasn't my fault says staying
alive by the bee gees
sam aard says best libertarian death
metal record ever is 1776 by king conker
their bases just passed away rest in
peace
seth klein says so glad to hear you
bring up handlebars by flobots it
depicts current reality perfectly you
see
andrew in the song handlebars by flobots
in the music video at the end there's a
guy challenging an authoritarian regime
and all of the jack boot cops banging
their shields have black lives matter
and the songs from because the communist
fist is the red salute but the song is
from i think like was it 13 years ago or
something yeah 14 years ago so they make
the song and the bad guys have the the
communist fist which is now the blm fest
right and they're killing people and
that's basically what the song is saying
that these people are like i can do
whatever i want no one can stop me
since everybody's telling me what rap
music i want to tell you what to listen
to all right you should go out and get
two albums
if that's what they call them
uh what what is when is ella and louie
and the other the others ella and louie
again best pop
ever made
you know you know my thing is though i
like um music for me i love political
music do you okay so so
there's some pop songs i might be like
oh yeah sure it's fun to play but i
really do like songs that have uh a
message
so i do like you know i've always been
critical my whole life of music that was
meaningless i grew up listening to a lot
of punk stuff okay and it started with
pop punk and then i listened to more
like actual punk stuff and then start
listening to more like independent music
and things like that but uh i i like i
like songs with meaning
uh
nothing really in between either just a
silly boppy whatever or it's gonna be
something so like all the stuff that i
write has deeper meaning all the songs
that i that i put together that we're
working on will of the people
has anyone said yet will of the people
yes that's right will of the people is
the greatest song ever
that's my song
tim actually super chatted that in
himself yeah
you guys gotta listen to that one that
was raymond g stanley jr thank you
raymond
that's right that sounds like that says
pim tool
oh here's a good idea brayden says y'all
should have all guests roll the 100 die
and rank them all on a leaderboard
almost like old top gear celebrity race
track laps that's a good idea here you
go andrew all right 100-sided diet so so
what do i have what am i doing here just
roll
it and there it goes we have the wine
challenge and uh no how do you know how
do you know what it is it's on the top
33 oh 33 that's my number big number i
rolled the 100 oh yeah that was hard
that was on
that was biden's during that during his
campaign yeah when was that was that
when lauren was drunk yeah yeah that was
fun all right everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to the channel share the show with your
friends and if you want to hear a
discussion about religion spirituality
philosophy and all of that crazy moral
and ethical stuff we're going to get
into that in the after show over at
timcast.com so sign up become a member
we greatly appreciate your support share
the show if you really do like our work
you can follow us at tim cast irl
basically everywhere you can follow me
at tim cast andrew do you want to shout
anything out
the truth and beauty you know should
pick it up it actually it's not written
for people who like poetry it's stress
written for people who want to look at
the world a different way cool
you know what i usually plug freedom
tunes got to plug something else though
i'll plug freedoms as well go check that
out earlier i made a digital evangelist
mostly not a fan but there are some
great ones like the original
televangelist fulton sheen i'm going to
shout him out go check out some bishop
fulton sheen videos they're incredible
what's the best place for people to get
your book right now amazon is always
helpful because it rises up the ranks
when you buy it and that's going to be i
want to shout out your twitter too
andrew clavin on twitter all right
thanks for coming man great to meet you
it's a pleasure it's really nice meeting
you guys ian crossland catch you guys
later and you guys may follow me on
twitter and mines.com at starpatchlets
as well as sourpatchlids.me
we will see you all at timcast.com just
about an hour or so thanks for hanging
out bye guys
you